I'm Jennifer Fisher and I'm Angela Kinsey. We were on the office together and we're best friends. And now we're doing the ultimate office rewatch podcast just for you. Each week we will break down an episode of the office and give exclusive behind the scene stories that only two people who were there can tell you. We're the office ladies. Hi! Alright, we are sitting across from each other. Off's ladies. Hi! Hi! Hi! Hi! Hi!
我是詹妮弗·费舍尔，我是安吉拉·金西。我们曾一起出演《办公室》，而且我们是最好的朋友。现在我们正在为你制作终极的《办公室》重温播客。每周我们都会剖析一集《办公室》，并分享只有身临其境的两人才能讲述的独家幕后故事。我们是办公室辣妹。嗨！好吧，我们面对面坐着。办公室辣妹。嗨！嗨！嗨！嗨！嗨！
Hi! Hi! Hi! Hi! Hi! Hi! Hi! Hi!
嗨！嗨！嗨！嗨！嗨！嗨！嗨！嗨！
Hi! Hi! Hi! Hi! Hi! Hi! Hi! Hi! Hi! bike lady. Aw. Today, we're talking about double date. It is season six, episode nine. It's written by Charlie Grandy, who is the writer famous for boom roasted and directed by Seth Gordon. Here's your summary.
嗨！嗨！嗨！嗨！嗨！嗨！嗨！嗨！嗨！骑单车的女士。啊。今天，我们要聊的是“双重约会”。这是第六季第九集。由以“Boom Roasted”闻名的编剧查理·格兰迪编剧，塞思·戈登执导。以下是剧情梗概。
Jim, Pam, Michael, and Pam's mom, Helene, all go out to lunch to celebrate Helene's birthday. This is the double date of double date. And it all goes well until Michael spirals out about Helene's real age and then he breaks up with her at her birthday lunch. Meanwhile Dwight does nice things for everyone in the office in an attempt to get each of them to owe him a favor, then he's going to cash in his favors to get Jim fired. But unfortunately for Dwight, Andy is also very good at favors. Andy will not owe you anything.
吉姆、帕姆、迈克尔和帕姆的妈妈海伦一起出去吃午饭，为海伦庆生。这就是双重一切的双重约会。一切都很顺利，直到迈克尔得知海伦的真实年龄后情绪失控，接着在她的生日午餐会上和她分手了。与此同时，德怀特在办公室里为每个人做好事，试图让每个人都欠他一个人情，然后他打算兑现这个人情来解雇吉姆。但对德怀特来说不幸的是，安迪也很擅长做人情。安迪可不会欠你任何人情。
I love it when he's like, you send me a wedding invitation? I respond. Yes, invite me to wedding invitation? I respond. Yes, invite me to your birthday boom, accepted. Yes, yeah. I would like that. It's a good quality. I mean, you know, you probably get a handwritten
我太喜欢他那种反应了，比如，你给我发了婚礼请柬？我回复。好的，邀请我参加婚礼请柬？我回复。好的，邀请我参加你的生日，太棒了，接受。是的，没错。我挺喜欢这样的。这是一个很好的品质。我的意思是，你知道，你可能会收到一封安迪手写的
thank you card from Andy. You probably do. All right, let's get into FastFacts. FastFact number one is all about our director, Seth Gordon. You know, we said last week, we're gonna get in to some of these like heavy hitter directors and Seth is another one. Yeah. I loved Seth because he directed one of my favorite movies of all time, the documentary, King of Kong, a fist full of quarters. It's so flipping good. It's so good and we rewatched it as a family.
感谢卡。你大概会的。好了，让我们进入“快速事实”。第一个快速事实是关于我们的导演塞思·戈登。你知道的，我们上周说过，我们要聊聊一些像重量级大牌那样的导演，塞思就是其中之一。是的。我很喜欢塞思，因为他导演了我最喜欢的电影之一，那部纪录片《金刚大战：四分之一硬币》。简直太酷了。太棒了，我们全家又看了一遍。
Did you? With the kids, if you do not know this documentary, you need to watch it immediately. It is about the world of competitive arcade gaming. Specifically, it follows this just gentle-hearted sweet guy named Steve Weebie in his attempt to beat the Donkey Kong high-score, which was held for like 20 years by this guy Billy Mitchell. Mm-hmm. Billy Mitchell is like the ultimate documentary villain. The story of these two guys battling it out
是吗？和孩子们一起，如果你不知道这部纪录片，你真的需要立刻去看看。它是关于竞技街机游戏的世界。具体来说，它讲述了一个内心善良、温和的家伙史蒂夫·韦比，他试图打破由一个叫比利·米切尔的家伙保持了大约20年的《大金刚》最高纪录的故事。嗯哼。比利·米切尔就像是纪录片里的终极反派。这两个家伙争夺
to have the high score on Donkey Kong. I couldn't love it more. When he would go on his garage in practice, yes. And his wife would like check in. I know. Oh my gosh, you guys, it is such a wonderful story. You can find it on Prime Video and Apple TV. We watched on Prime, we had to buy it.
《大金刚》最高纪录的故事。我太喜欢了。当他去车库练习时，是的。而他的妻子会来查看。我知道。哦天哪，伙计们，这是一个多么精彩的故事。你可以在 Prime Video 和 Apple TV 上找到它。我们在 Prime 上看的，我们得买下来。
I'm so glad we did. So Seth Gordon, he did everything on this movie, he directed it, he was the cinematographer, he edited it. And then he came and did our show. So we got another documentary and film director. I looked through my digital clutter lady, and I actually emailed a friend of mine saying how excited I was to have Seth on set
我太高兴我们这么做了。所以塞思·戈登，他包办了这部电影的所有工作，他执导了这部电影，他是摄影师，他还负责剪辑。然后他来拍了我们的剧。所以我们又迎来了另一位纪录片和电影导演。我在我的数字杂物里翻找了一番，女士，我还真的给我的一位朋友发过电子邮件，说我有多么兴奋能让塞思加入剧组
and that we were all really excited. And then I also said, and I have a day off, because of the double date story. A double date story. And guess what I did with my day off? What? I did an episode of Yo Gabba Gabba. Oh, I remember that, Anne.
并且我们大家都非常兴奋。然后我还说，因为“双重约会”的剧情，我有一天假。一个双重约会的故事。你猜我休假那天干了什么？什么？我去拍了一集《Yo Gabba Gabba》。哦，我记得那个，安。
Yeah, because my daughter loved the show, and I went to the set, I got to play the school teacher. I had to sing about Show and Tell. Here it is. Time for Show and Tell. Time for Show and Tell. Show is what you can do. Oh my gosh, well done, Angela. Time for Show and Tell, time for Show and Tell, show us what you can do!
是的，因为我女儿很喜欢这个节目，我去了片场，我有幸扮演学校老师。我得唱一首关于“展示与分享”的歌。就是这样。展示与分享的时间到。展示与分享的时间到。展示就是你能做到的事。哦天哪，干得好，安吉拉。展示与分享的时间到，展示与分享的时间到，展示给我们看你能做到的事！
Oh my gosh, well done, Angela! Time for Show and Tell! I had to sing and dance. You know these are things I do not do, but it's what you do for your kids. It's well so excited. They gave me this great picture of her and I on set with all of the characters and I have it in my office. It's so cute. And everyone there was so nice. They were so much fun. It was one of the most fun days of work I've ever had. Every day on Yogyabagabba was a theme day. And that day was birthday day.
哦天哪，干得好，安吉拉！展示与分享的时间到！我还得唱歌跳舞。你知道这些都是我平时不会做的事，但为了孩子，你什么都愿意做。真的是超级兴奋。他们给了我一张很棒的照片，是我和所有角色在片场的合影，我把它放在我的办公室里。太可爱了。那里的每个人都超级好。他们太有趣了。那是我经历过的最有趣的工作日之一。在《Yo Gabba Gabba》的每一天都是主题日。那天是生日主题日。
And you would come dressed as whatever your interpretation of that was. And this one gal came dressed as a cake, like fully a cake, like a hat and a skirt, but she was a tiered cake. You would wear that. You love a birthday. I do love a birthday.
你会根据自己对这个主题的理解打扮得奇奇怪怪地来。有个姑娘打扮成了一个蛋糕，完完全全就是一个蛋糕，戴着帽子，穿着裙子，她成了一个分层蛋糕。你才会穿成那样呢。你最喜欢过生日了。我确实很喜欢生日。
Should we start having theme days on our tape days here at Office Ladies? We've got a lot of pressure. It feels like a lot of pressure. Okay, we won't do it. Maybe once. We'll do one theme day. We'll do one. Sam, you have to do it. Maybe once. We'll do one theme day. We'll do one.
我们是不是也该在《办公室辣妹》的录制日搞点主题日？我们压力好大啊。感觉压力山大。好吧，那就算了。也许偶尔一次。我们就搞一个主题日。就搞一次。萨姆，你可得参加。也许偶尔一次。我们就搞一个主题日。就搞一次。
Sam, you have to participate. Everyone participates. I would love to. Okay. Theme day coming up. Well, before we move to FastFact number two, let me also add that Seth Gordon has gone on to direct huge movies,
萨姆，你必须参加。每个人都要参与。我很乐意。好吧。主题日即将到来。好吧，在我们进入第二个快速事实之前，我还要补充一点，塞思·戈登后来执导了许多大片，
four Christmas's, horrible bosses, identity theft and Baywatch. He's also directed a ton of television. I loved working with him. I loved him. So now, FastFact number two is a location breakdown. Is it of the restaurant? Yes. I mean, so much of this episode takes place at this restaurant, Paparazos, not a real restaurant. We made it up. We filmed it in Los Angeles at this place called Beastro Garden in Studio City. I was going to say, wait, I'm serving past that.
《四个圣诞节》、《恶老板》、《身份窃匪》和《海滩游侠》。他还执导过大量的电视剧。我很喜欢跟他合作。我超喜欢他。那么现在，第二个快速事实是一个取景地解析。是关于那家餐厅的吗？是的。我的意思是，这集的很大一部分都是在这家叫帕帕拉佐斯的餐厅拍摄的，这不是一家真正的餐厅。我们凭空捏造的。我们在洛杉矶名为“演播室城比斯特罗花园”的地方拍摄的。我本想说，等等，我正要说到那儿。
Yeah, I've eaten there. It's at the corner of Coldwater, in Ventura. Oh, yeah, with the big awning and the steps. Yes. Yes. It's now closed, but it was a really great restaurant. When I reached out to our writer on this episode, Charlie Grandy, to ask him about some of his memories that we might be able to share, he reminded me that there was a giant water main break on Coldwater Canyon Road that exploded and flooded
对，我在那里吃过饭。它在科尔德沃特和文图拉的交界处。哦，对，有那个大遮阳篷和台阶。没错。是的。现在已经关门了，但它真的是一家很棒的餐厅。当我联系这集的编剧查理·格兰迪，向他询问一些我们或许能分享的回忆时，他提醒我，科尔德沃特峡谷路曾发生过一次巨大的水管爆裂，导致水流喷涌而出，淹没了
the whole area. Yes, I remember that. And that was like the day before we were supposed to shoot in this area. I used to live off this road of Coldwater Canyon. There was one way in and one way out of my neighborhood and it was this road where this water main broke. Randy Courtree confirmed that this happened and it caused a huge problem with this intersection. There were hundreds of thousands of gallons of water. It was about four feet deep. There was all this traffic. it took like three days to clean it up, some
整个地区。对，我记得。那大概是我们计划在这个地区拍摄的前一天。我以前就住在科尔德沃特峡谷这条路附近。我的社区只有一条进出的路，就是水管爆裂的这条路。兰迪·科德里证实了这件事，这给这个十字路口造成了巨大的麻烦。有几十万加仑的水。水深大约有四英尺。到处都是交通拥堵。清理工作花了大约三天时间，有个
guy had to be rescued from his car. All the businesses along that street flooded, and had to be closed, and some of them had to be renovated, and some didn't even come back, because it was too much damage. And you know what I remember? I remember right on cold water, a few days after the flood, there was a sinkhole. Yes, and they had a giant hole in the ground. Lady, I found a picture of it. This was in the LA Times. Yes, it was crazy. And then they had to fix the sinkhole by laying these big metal plate things on the ground.
家伙不得不从他的车里被救出来。沿街的所有商铺都被水淹了，不得不关门，其中一些不得不重新装修，有些甚至再也没有开业，因为损失太惨重了。你知道我还记得什么吗？我记得就在科尔德沃特街上，洪水退去几天后，出现了一个天坑。是的，地上有一个巨大的洞。女士，我找到了一张照片。这曾登上过《洛杉矶时报》。是的，太疯狂了。然后他们不得不通过在地面上铺设这些巨大的金属板来修补这个天坑。
And when you drove over, it was like, good, good, good, good, good, good, good, good, good, good, good, good, good, good, good, good, good, good, good, good, good, good, good, good, good, good, good, good, good, good, good, good, good, good, good, good, good, good, good, good, good, good, good, good, good, good, good, good, good, good, good, good, good, good, good, good, good, good, good, good, good, good, good, good, good, good, good, good, good, good, good, good, good, good, good, good, good, good, good, good, good, good, good, good, good, good, good, good, good, good, good, good, good, good, good, good, good, good, good, good, good, good, good, good, good, good, good, good, good, good, good, good, good, good, good, good, good, good, good, good, good, good, good, good, good, good, good, good, good, good, good, good, good, good, good, good, good, good, good, good, good, good, good, good, good, good, good, good, good, good, good, good, good, good, good, good, good, good, good, good, good, good, good, good, good, good, good, good, good, good, good, good, good, good, good, good, good, good, good, good, good, good, good, good, good, good, good, good, good, good, good, good, good, good, good, good, good, good, good, good, good, good, good, good, good, good, good, good, good, good, good, good car passes. The traffic was a son of a bull. It was. Amazingly enough, the bistro where we were shooting did not flood, and they found a way that we could access it from this back road, and we still shot that day. Wow. Yeah. All right, fast-back number three, Angela. Mm-hmm. The other memory that Charlie Granty shared was that he got a blackberry during this episode. He finally upgraded his flip phone, but he said he did not know how to set it up. So he asked John to help him to set up his blackberry on set because John was the voice of Blackberry. Oh yeah, John had one. He had to know how to use it because he was like part of a campaign.
当你开车碾过时，声音就像是，好，好，好，好，好，好，好，好，好，好，好，好，好，好，好，好，好，好，好，好，好，好，好，好，好，好，好，好，好，好，好，好，好，好，好，好，好，好，好，好，好，好，好，好，好，好，好，好，好，好，好，好，好，好，好，好，好，好，好，好，好，好，好，好，好，好，好，好，好，好，好，好，好，好，好，好，好，好，好，好，好，好，好，好，好，好，好，好，好，好，好，好，好，好，好，好，好，好，好，好，好，好，好，好，好，好，好，好，好，好，好，好，好，好，好，好，好，好，好，好，好，好，好，好，好，好，好，好，好，好，好，好，好，好，好，好，好，好，好，好，好，好，好，好，好，好，好，好，好，好，好，好，好，好，好，好，好，好，好，好，好，好，好，好，好，好，好，好，好，好，好，好，好，好，好，好，好，好，好，好，好，好，好，好，好，好，好，好，好，好，好，好，好，好，好，好，好，好，好，好，好，好，好，好，好，好，好，好，好，好，好，好，好，好，好，好，好，好，好，好，好，好，好，好，好，好，好，好，好，好，好，好，好，好，好，好，好，好，好，好，好，好，好，好，好，好，好，好，好，好，好，好，好，好，好，好，好，好，好，好，好，好，好，好，好，好，好，好，好，好，好，好，好，好，好，好，好，好，好，好，好，好，好，好，好，好，好，好，好，好，好，好，好，好，好，好，好，好，好，好，好，好，好，好，好，好，好，好，好，好，好，好，好，好，好，好，好，好，好，好，好，好，好，好，好，好，好，好，好，好，好，好，好，好，好，好，好，好，好，好，好，好，好，好，好，好，好，好，好，好，好，好，好，好，好，好，好，好，好，好，好，好，好，好，好，好，好，好，好，好，好，好，好，好，好，好汽车驶过。交通简直糟糕透顶。确实如此。神奇的是，我们拍摄的那家小酒馆并没有被淹，他们找到了一条能让我们从这条后路进去的通道，我们那天照常拍摄了。哇。是的。好了，第三个快速事实，安吉拉。嗯哼。查理·格兰迪分享的另一个记忆是，他在拍这集的时候买了一部黑莓手机。他终于把他的翻盖手机升级了，但他却说他不知道怎么设置。于是他在片场请约翰帮他设置黑莓手机，因为约翰是黑莓的代言人。哦对，约翰有一部。他必须知道怎么用，因为他是某个宣传活动的一部分。
Yeah, I found an audio clip. Oh. What's this? The new Blackberry? You've seen Blackberries before, it's no big deal. Maybe one quick peek. Just to see what all the fuss is about. Whoa.
嗯哼。看一眼就好。只是想看看大家都在大惊小怪什么。哇。
Mm-hmm. one quick peak. Just to see what all the fuss is about. Whoa. Mm hmm. So this was when Blackberry was getting away from the little buttons, and they were just like going to become a touch screen Blackberry. So that's why he's like, whoa, he has a really good voice for that. He's done tons of voiceovers. I know. So anyway, I loved that Charlie had a memory that during different setups, he'd be like getting John to set up his new Blackberry forum. It's so funny because, you know, like when you're talking to someone and they all of a sudden tell you something
嗯哼。看一眼就好。只是想看看大家都在大惊小怪什么。哇。嗯哼。所以这是黑莓开始放弃小按键，准备转型为全触屏黑莓的时候。这就是为什么他会说“哇”，他真的有一副很适合这个的嗓音。他做过大量的配音工作。我知道。总之，我很喜欢查理的一个回忆，就是在不同的布景间隙，他会找约翰帮他设置他的新黑莓手机。太搞笑了，因为，你知道的，就像当你和某人聊天时，他们突然告诉你一件事，
and all of these memories flood back. Yeah. So that's now happened twice today. First of all, the sinkhole. I remember the sinkhole. Secondly, I remember getting my Blackberry and having rain help me. Yeah. Rain got so frustrated with me because he was like, Angela, you're not listening.
然后所有的记忆如潮水般涌来。是的。所以今天这已经是第二次发生这种情况了。首先是天坑。我还记得那个天坑。其次，我记得我拿到黑莓手机时，是雷恩帮我的。是的，雷恩对我都快无语了，因为他当时说，安吉拉，你根本没在听。
Yeah, because rain was the first one to get one. Yeah, but I just remember rain help me set up my blackberry. Well, that's all I got for fast facts. Well, I loved your fast facts. They took me down memory lane, and this is such a fun episode. I got for Fast Facts. Well, I loved your Fast Facts. They took me down memory lane, and this is such a fun episode. I was so delighted by it, I can't wait for us to just get right into it. I had forgotten about so much of it, so I loved it too.
对，因为雷恩是第一个拿到黑莓的人。对，但我只记得雷恩帮我设置我的黑莓手机了。好吧，我的快速事实就这些了。嗯，我喜欢你的快速事实。它们带我重温了过去的回忆，而且这一集真的很有趣。我的快速事实就这些了。嗯，我喜欢你的快速事实。它们带我重温了过去的回忆，而且这一集真的很有趣。我被它逗得很开心，我迫不及待地想让我们直接开始吧。我已经忘了里面的好多内容，所以我也很喜欢。
Well, how about this? Let's go to break, because when we come back, lady, I brought in one of my journals. Oh! Oh! This day is awesome. Things are gonna get spussy! We are back! Dwight is walking around with, I want you to know, what I think was a very nice basket. I know this is a basket. He's got all of these beautiful bagels from Agen H. Bagel in New York, and he has started his favorite campaign. Yeah, I'll have you know, Agen H. Bagels is a real
好吧，这样如何？我们先休息一下，因为等我们回来时，女士，我带来了我的一本日志。哦！哦！今天太棒了。事情要变得有意思了！我们回来了！德怀特正带着一个，我想让你们知道，我认为非常漂亮的篮子四处走动。我知道这是个篮子。他带着来自纽约 Agen H. Bagel 的所有这些精美的百吉饼，他开始了他人气大爆发的活动。是的，我要提醒你们，Agen H. Bagels 是纽约一家真实存在的
place in New York. It's very famous for having the best bagels. And this is also not the first time that H&H Biggles has been featured on a television show. What was the other show? Seinfeld. Oh, yeah. And I have an audio clip. Oh my gosh.
店。它以拥有最美味的百吉饼而闻名。这也是 H&H Bagels 第一次在电视节目中亮相。另一个节目是什么？《宋飞传》。哦，对。我有一段音频。哦天哪。
Great news. Yeah, the strike's been settled. I'm going back to work. What's the other guy, H&H bagels? That's where I worked. You worked? Bagels? Yeah, look, see.
好消息。对，罢工解决了。我要回去工作了。另一个是什么来着，H&H Bagels？那就是我工作的地方。你工作过？百吉饼？对，你看，瞧。
It's still on my business card. We've been on strike for 12 years. I've never seen those guys picketing out there, but haven't seen him in a long time. Well, H&H would let us use their bathroom while we were picketing. Put a crimp in our solidarity. You're demands. Yeah, 5.35 an hour, and that's what they're paying now. I believe that's the new minimum wage.
我的名片还在呢。我们已经罢工12年了。我从没见过那些家伙在外面举牌抗议，不过好久没见到他了。嗯，我们在外面抗议的时候，H&H 会让我们用他们的洗手间。这可削弱了我们的团结。你们的诉求。对，一小时5块35美分，他们现在就是这个价。我猜那是新的最低工资标准。
And now you know who to thank for that. All right, I gotta go. Why didn't you ever mention this? Well, gee, I didn't want you to know I was out of work. It's embarrassing. So this is the storyline that suddenly you find out that Kramer had a job, that he's been on strike, and it was age and age bagels, and he goes back to the bagel place, and he gets his job back. But he doesn't know, like, he gets there, and I ended up watching the episode.
现在你知道该感谢谁了。好了，我得走了。你以前怎么从来没提过这事？哦，天哪，我可不想让你知道我失业了。太尴尬了。所以这就是那个剧情线，你突然发现原来克莱默有一份工作，他一直在罢工，而且就是在 H&H 烤面包圈店，然后他又回到了那家店，重新得到了那份工作。但他不知道，他到了那里，我最后看了那一集。
I can't tell. And he gets there, and he up watching the episode. I can't tell. And he gets there and he's like, Raisin bagel. We're putting raisins in them. And you're like, yeah, I mean, the raisin bagel. He's like, all right, I can do it. It was very funny. But I'll have you know that the bagels that Dwight
我看不出来。他到了那里，我最后看了那一集。我看不出来。他到了那里，然后他说，葡萄干百吉饼。我们在里面加葡萄干。然后你就说，对啊，我是说，葡萄干百吉饼。他说，好吧，我能搞定。非常搞笑。不过我要让你们知道，德怀特
is passing out were not actually H&H bagels from New York. They were from a place called Western Bagel Invinize. Western Bagel's very good too. I've been there. I have a little something to share about H&H. What is it? Why are you reaching in a bag? I'm reaching for my journal.
分发的百吉饼实际上并不是来自纽约的 H&H 百吉饼。它们来自一个叫 Western Bagel 的地方，在范奈斯。Western Bagel 也很好吃。我去过那儿。我有个关于 H&H 的小故事要分享。是什么？你为什么在包里掏？我在掏我的日志。
What? Get ready. Okay, the first bagel I ever had was an H&H bagel and it was when I was interning on late night with Conan O'Brien. Stop it right now. This journal, it's a flower journal. It has many posted notes sticking out of it.
什么？准备好了吗。好吧，我吃过的第一个百吉饼就是一个 H&H 百吉饼，那是我在《柯南·奥布莱恩深夜秀》实习的时候。立刻给我打住。这本日志，是一本花卉日记。上面贴了好多便利贴。
Pages are falling out, and there is a late night with Conan O'Brien sticker. I got the sticker when I got the internship, and I put it on my journal. I mean, I'm taking a picture of you, obviously. All right, before we turn to the page where I talk about my first bagel experience, I interned on Conan O'Brien.
书页都在掉落，上面还有一个《柯南·奥布莱恩深夜秀》的贴纸。我是在得到这份实习工作时拿到这个贴纸的，然后我把它贴在了日志上。我的意思是，我显然在给你拍照。好吧，在我们翻到我记录第一次吃百吉饼经历的那一页之前，我在柯南的节目实习过。
Years later, over a decade later, I was asked to be a guest. It was a full circle life moment because I went from the person who was getting everyone's coffee to actually being a guest. And I brought my journal when I was a guest and I read this on late night with Conan. Ready? Yes. I cannot wait. Turning to the page. Here we go. Tomorrow night is Conan's first year anniversary party at the Museum of Modern Art. Lots of important people, stars,
多年后，十多年后，我被邀请作为嘉宾上节目。这是一个圆满的人生时刻，因为我从那个帮每个人买咖啡的人，变成了真正的嘉宾。我去当嘉宾时带上了我的日志，并在柯南的深夜秀上读了这段。准备好了吗？是的。我迫不及待了。翻到这一页。我们开始吧。明天晚上是柯南在现代艺术博物馆举办的一周年庆祝派对。有许多重要人物、明星、
NBC folks, and the interns get to go. Wow! Details later! What am I? Details later to myself? This is my journal. I go on to say. And there are serious food perks to interning here. I get a free meal with the writers, and I had my first bagel. It's basically bread that looks like a donut. No, you did not just describe what a bagel is in your journal to myself. Just in case you forget later. Just in case someone finds this journal someday, and they're curious curious what is a bagel and they're curious what's going to happen at Conan's party details later. Yeah. Oh yeah. Keep going please. No that's it. Okay. No please.
NBC 的员工，实习生也可以去。哇！细节稍后补充！我这是什么？自言自语说细节稍后补充？这就是我的日志。我接着写道。在这里实习有很大的食物福利。我和编剧们一起吃免费工作餐，我还吃了我人生中的第一个百吉饼。它基本上就是长得像甜甜圈的面包。不，你刚刚没有在日志里自言自语地描述什么是百吉饼吧。以防你以后忘了。万一哪天有人发现了这本日志，他们会好奇百吉饼到底是什么，也会好奇柯南的派对上会发生什么，细节稍后补充。对。哦，是的。请继续。不，就这些。好吧。不，请。
Okay. Please. Let's see. Did you ever write the details later? I did. I don't know if I can read them. Okay. This is what the journal becomes just for you. Yeah. Okay. In a nutshell, Conan's party. The interns had to work the front door. So you have to go.
好吧。请吧。让我看看。你后来真的写了细节吗？写了。我不知道我能不能读出来。好吧。这就是这本专门为你准备的日志。简而言之，柯南的派对。实习生们必须在前门当门童。所以你得去。
But I had to work. We had a list of names of people who could come in. After working the party, we got to come inside at the end and we got to have drinks. We all got tuted. Oh my gosh. Wait, can you go back and read your description of what a bagel is one more time? I just want to hear it again.
但我得工作。我们有一份可以入场的人员名单。工作结束后，我们最后得以进入内场，还喝了饮料。我们都喝嗨了。哦天哪。等等，你能回去再读一遍你对百吉饼的描述吗？我只想再听一遍。
Yes. And there's some serious food perks to interning here. I get a free meal with the writers. And I had my first bagel. It's basically bread that looks like a donut. Okay. I'm sorry, you guys got what? At the party, what did you guys get? Tooted.
好的。在这里实习有一些很好的食物福利。我和编剧们一起吃免费工作餐，我还吃了我人生中的第一个百吉饼。它基本上就是长得像甜甜圈的面包。好吧。抱歉，你们在派对上得到了什么？在派对上，你们得到了什么？喝嗨了。
What time period does this take place? You guys, this is 1994. I got tooted. I got tooted on free drinks after work in the door all night. I'm sorry, I need a mug that has a picture of a bagel. And underneath it says, it basically brash like a donut. I'm like, there you guys go. My first age in age bagel.
这是什么年代发生的事？伙计们，这是1994年。我喝嗨了。下班后喝着免费饮料在门口站了一整晚，我喝嗨了。抱歉，我需要一个马克杯，上面印着一个百吉饼的照片。然后在下面写着，它基本上就是长得像甜甜圈的面包。我心想，给你们。我人生的第一个 H&H 百吉饼。
And now you know how lame my was in my 20s. Your journal reads like how they write Michael Scott's journal. It's amazing. It's amazing. Oh my gosh. Please bring it back again to some other time. Please just keep reading it. Oh my gosh.
现在你们知道我二十多岁时有多无趣了吧。你的日志读起来就像迈克尔·斯科特的日志一样。太神奇了。太神奇了。哦天哪。请什么时候再把它拿出来读读吧。求你继续读下去吧。哦天哪。
Oh my gosh. Okay. All right. All right, back to the episode. I'm sorry, okay. Okay, back to the episode. You know when Dwight went in to offer Michael the bagels? Yes. And Michael claims he isn't hungry
哦天哪。好吧。好了。好了，回到剧情。抱歉，好吧。好吧，回到剧情。你知道当德怀特进去给迈克尔送百吉饼的时候吗？是的。迈克尔声称他不饿，
because he had two fish stick sandwiches, which were an aphrodisiac. Right, but his lady friend declined. Yes. Dwight says something like, you're thinking of deer penis. I was thinking of oysters. There are many things that are aphrodisiacs. Oh, no.
因为他吃了两个鱼柳三明治，那可是催情春药。对，但是他的女伴拒绝了。是的。德怀特说了一句类似的话，你想到的是鹿鞭。我想到的是生蚝。有很多东西都是催情春药。哦，不。
I sense a deep dive. But I was most curious. No, you did not type dear penis. I did type is dear penis and aphrodisiac. Oh Lord Jesus. It is. What? It's real.
我感觉有一场深度挖掘要来了。但我最好奇的是。不，你可别在网上搜了“鹿鞭”。我确实搜了“鹿鞭是催情春药吗”。哦天哪耶稣。确实是。什么？真的。
Come on. Yeah, it goes all the way back to Hippocrates. Recommended dear penis as a solution to, quote, resolving sexual difficulties. But that's not all. According to Wikipedia, in traditional Chinese medicine, deer penis is thought to have like other therapeutic properties.
拜托。是的，这可以一直追溯到希波克拉底。他推荐鹿鞭作为解决“呃，解决性功能障碍”的方案。但这还不是全部。根据维基百科，在传统中医学中，鹿鞭被认为具有其他治疗特性。
There's something called deer penis wine. No. Yep, no. Yep, you can get it for about $12 a glass. Get away from me with your deer penis wine. It supposedly can help heal athletic injuries. Well, I'm not athletic, so. But if you don't want deer penis wine,
有一种东西叫鹿鞭酒。不。没错，不。没错，你大概花12美元就能买到一杯。离我远点，带着你的鹿鞭酒。据说它有助于治疗运动损伤。好吧，我又不爱运动，所以。但如果你不想要鹿鞭酒，
you could have three penis wine. What? Three penises. Who's three penises? A seal penis. Stop it. A deer penis and a dog penis. Come on!
你可以喝三鞭酒。什么？三个鞭。谁的三个鞭？海豹鞭。住手。鹿鞭和狗鞭。拜托！
Who is making wine out of a bunch of penises? I don't know, but you can get it, and since I was in studio to know. No, no, no, I'm not drinking it. I'm not drinking it. I'm not drinking it. You did not bring dear penis wine. No. I know, I didn't. I didn't.
谁会用一堆动物的生殖器来酿酒啊？我不知道，不过你能买到，而且既然我在录音室里，就想知道。不，不，不，我可不喝。我不喝。我不喝。你该不会真的带了鹿鞭酒来吧。没有。我知道，我没带。我没带。
Oh my God. Oh my God. I didn't. I was just kidding. Oh my God. But I did find a website called Aal Sessions, and this person did drink three penis wine, and I thought I'd read you the description.
天哪。天哪。我没带。我开玩笑呢。天哪。不过我确实找到一个叫 Aal Sessions 的网站，这个人真的喝过三鞭酒，我想我读给你听听它的描述。
Okay, here's what they said. Quote. It's something along the lines of an expired port with a pungent vinegar taste and some prune juice. And if you thought you'd get away with not tasting the three different penis profiles you thought wrong. Also, it does not work in cocktails because it really just overpowers any possible combinations. You think the multiple penises overpower the other flavors? The writer said no one should consume more than just a sip of this concoction. No one should consume more than just a sip of this concoction. If you truly are interested in tasting the weirdest of the weird, three penis wine can generally be found in select Chinese grocers? It is sold on the shelves as it is classified as more of a natural herbal drink than alcohol,
好吧，他们是这样说的。引用。这有点像过期波特酒，带有刺鼻的醋味和一些西梅汁。如果你以为自己能逃过一劫，不用品尝这三种不同的生殖器风味，那你就想错了。另外，它不适合用来调酒，因为它实在太抢味了，会压倒任何可能的鸡尾酒搭配。你觉得这多种生殖器的风味盖过了其他味道？作者说谁也不应该喝超过一小口这玩意儿。谁也不应该喝超过一小口这玩意儿。如果你真的对品尝最诡异的东西感兴趣，三鞭酒通常可以在精选的华人杂货店里买到？它在货架上出售，因为它更多被归类为天然草本饮料，而不是酒精饮料，
but honestly, don't drink this. It's not good, but that should be fairly obvious already. I don't even know what to say. I am just thinking about these poor animals. How are they getting the penises? I can't. I didn't want to know, but what they do is they like soak the penises in something.
但老实说，别喝这东西。不好喝，不过这应该已经很明显了。我甚至不知道该说什么了。我满脑子都在想那些可怜的动物。他们是怎么搞到这些生殖器的？我受不了了。我其实不想知道，不过他们好像是把这些生殖器浸泡在某种东西里。
There's also something called baby mouse wine. It's like a jar of baby mice and then it ferments and then you drink it. For what? I don't know, but you know, when you're googling three penis wine, all these weird wines come up. Just weird drinks, you know? There's articles about the weirdest drinks. I know, okay, note to self, do not Google
还有一种叫小老鼠酒。就像是一罐泡着小老鼠的酒，然后发酵了，再喝下去。为了什么？我不知道，不过你知道的，当你搜索三鞭酒的时候，所有这些奇怪的酒都会跳出来。就是一些奇怪的饮品，你知道的？有很多关于最奇怪饮品的文章。好吧，记住，切勿在谷歌上搜索
about penis wine. Well, a sentence I never thought I would say out loud. Well, just like we weren't the first show to feature H&H bagels, we aren't the first show to mention deer penis. Three penis wine was also a plotline of an episode of the league where they drink it. Well, I don't know what you thought you were going to hear today on office ladies. A bagel looks like a donut. There's penis wine. Um, a bagel looks like a donut. There's penis wine.
关于XX酒的东西。好吧，这是我做梦也没想到自己会大声说出的一句话。好吧，就像我们不是第一个出现 H&H 百吉饼的节目一样，我们也不是第一个提到鹿鞭的节目。《联盟》有一集的剧情里他们也喝了三鞭酒。好吧，我不知道你以为今天在《办公室辣妹》里会听到什么。百吉饼长得像甜甜圈。有XX酒。嗯，百吉饼长得像甜甜圈。有XX酒。
I, anything can happen, guys, anything. I don't have much else for the rest of the episodes. So the scale is tipped to hear at the top of the show just with the cold open. I have two more things about this cold open. Oh my gosh, we're not done with the cold open. We're not. At 19 seconds, I got a coffee mug callback. What's that? I love a coffee mug callback.
我，任何事情都可能发生，伙计们，任何事。对于剩下的剧情，我没有太多要说的了。所以天平在节目一开始就因为这个冷场笑话而倾斜了。关于这个冷场笑话，我还有两件事要说。哦天哪，我们还没聊完冷场笑话？还没呢。在19秒的时候，我发现了一个咖啡马克杯的彩蛋。是什么？我太喜欢咖啡马克杯的彩蛋了。
Andy has his mug from Kelly's America's Got Talent viewing party sitting on his desk. Also, this was not the cold open in the shooting draft. Really? Yeah, there was a whole different cold open. Here's what it said. Cold open interior Michael's what it said. Cold open interior Michael's office. Michael sits at his desk,
安迪的桌上放着他在凯莉的《美国达人秀》观影派对上用过的那个马克杯。另外，这并不是拍摄初稿里的冷场笑话。真的吗？对，原本有一个完全不同的冷场笑话。内容是这样的。冷场室内迈克尔的办公室。迈克尔坐在办公桌前，
flipping through a small stack of pictures. He sees Jim walking by. Jim, Jim, you have to see this, regarding the photo. Do you know who that is? Jim, no, Michael, come on, how can you not tell? The T-shirt, the jeans, Jim? Is it you, Michael? I'm flattered, but it's Johnny Depp. Jim, really? Where did you take these?
翻看一小叠照片。他看到吉姆走过。吉姆，吉姆，你得来看看这个，指着照片。你知道那是谁吗？吉姆，不知道，迈克尔，拜托，你怎么会认不出来？T恤，牛仔裤，吉姆？是你吗，迈克尔？我很荣幸，但这是约翰尼·德普。吉姆，真的吗？你在哪拍的这些？
Michael, my condo complex. Jim, of course, and what was he doing there? Michael, keep this on the download, but he was moving in. Jim, right, because I read in people that Johnny Depp was looking for a two bedroom and Scranton. Michael, I'm totally flipping. You know my idea for a fourth Pirates movie, right? So this goes on and on. Michael is convinced that Johnny Depp has moved in and is his neighbor.
迈克尔，我的公寓小区。吉姆，当然了，他在那儿干嘛？迈克尔，保密，但他正准备搬进来。吉姆，没错，因为我在《人物》杂志上看到约翰尼·德普正在斯克兰顿找一套两居室。迈克尔，我简直疯了。你知道我拍第四部《加勒比海盗》的点子吧？所以这段剧情一直继续。迈克尔坚信约翰尼·德普已经搬过来成了他的邻居。
And as it turns out, when he goes to see Johnny Depp's mailbox, it says, M.Schulman. So it's not Johnny Depp. I'm surprised Michael doesn't think that's an alias. It is a really funny scene and we shot it and it also includes Michael's impression of Jack Sparrow. That exists somewhere. You know, this is crazy. This is unlocking a memory for me when we read that at the table read. We all thought that was so funny. Yeah. Amazing.
结果证明，当他去看约翰尼·德普的信箱时，上面写着：M.舒尔曼。所以根本不是约翰尼·德普。我很惊讶迈克尔居然不觉得那是个化名。这真的是个非常搞笑的场景，我们拍了，里面还包括迈克尔模仿杰克·斯派罗船长。那段内容肯定在某个地方存着。你知道的，这太疯狂了，当我们读到那场围读时，这唤醒了我的记忆。我们当时都觉得太搞笑了。太棒了。
Are we closing out the cold open? That's it. We're done with the cold open. All right. Let's move in to the episode. Dwight goes up to Pam's desk and offers her a bagel. She doesn't want one because she's having an early lunch. This is when we find out the information that she's going on this double date for her mom's birthday.
我们要结束冷场笑话了吗？就这些。冷场笑话结束了。好吧。让我们进入正题。德怀特走到帕姆的桌前，给她递了一个百吉饼。她不想要，因为她要吃早午餐。这时我们得知了一个消息，她要为她妈妈的生日去进行双重约会。
We had a fan question from Genevieve B and Omaha, Nebraska. Why is Pam wearing such neutral, earthy colors in this episode? Normally, she would be wearing at least a little pop of color, but in this episode, she looks like she's dressing dare I say, like Dwight. What? I see what she's saying. The color palette is very truity,
我们收到了来自内布拉斯加州奥马哈的粉丝杰内维夫·B 的提问。为什么帕姆在这集中穿得这么中性、这么像大地色系？通常她至少会穿一点亮色，但在这集中，她看起来穿得——我敢说——简直就像德怀特。什么？我懂她的意思。色调非常朴素，
but I also noticed that everything about it was, there was no color. I think Pam is in mourning. I think she is going on this double date. And she like, when she looked in her closet, this is what spoke to her. I have noticed since Pam has become a salesman that her whole outfit has become more muted. There's less pop of color. Yeah. I've noticed that too. We're going to get it back. Okay. Ryan is continuing to evolve. Who is Ryan? He's the hat-wearing glasses guy.
但我也注意到这一切都是毫无色彩的。我觉得帕姆在服丧。我觉得她要去参加这个双重约会。当她看着自己的衣橱时，这就是她内心的真实写照。我注意到自从帕姆成为销售员后，她的整套穿搭都变得更加低调了。亮色变少了。是的。我也注意到了。我们会把它找回来的。好吧。瑞恩还在继续进化。谁是瑞恩？就是那个戴帽子戴眼镜的家伙。
Now he's a photographer. He's showing his portfolio to Aaron. It's a black and white series that he calls exposure in the workplace. I wrote down the images I saw. Do tell. One looks like some drains on the side of the building. Mm-hmm. Another one is clearly the Dundermiffland parking lot. You can see the top of Meredith's van, the hedge and the sign. And then, of course, we have Kelly Newdy from the way stuck at her desk. We had a fan question from Cecilia P. in Minnesota who would like to know what is this photo book? How did we take the photo of Mindy? I want to know everything. Let's hear it.
现在他成了摄影师。他正在向艾琳展示他的作品集。这是一系列黑白照片，他称之为“职场曝光”。我记下了我看到的画面。快讲讲。一张看起来像是大楼侧面的排水沟。嗯哼。另一张显然是邓德米夫林的停车场。你可以看到梅雷迪思面包车的顶部、树篱和招牌。然后，当然，还有凯莉·纽迪卡在办公桌上的样子。我们收到了来自明尼苏达州塞西莉亚·P 的粉丝提问，她想知道这本写真集是什么？我们是怎么给曼迪拍照的？我想知道一切。说来听听。
Well, Randy Cordray told us that all of the photos were shot by our production designer Michael Gallenberg. He would do that for the show. For example, you mentioned that coffee mug, Michael took the pictures of all the cast members that then Phil Shay put on the coffee mugs. He's actually a very talented real-life still photographer. So he did all of these photos. And the shoot with Mindy was done with her wearing like a flesh-colored bandeau.
好吧，兰迪·科德里告诉我们，所有的照片都是由我们的美术指导迈克尔·加伦伯格拍摄的。他会为节目做这些事。比如，你提到了那个咖啡马克杯，迈克尔拍了所有演员的照片，然后菲尔·谢把它们印在了马克杯上。他实际上是一个非常有才华的现实生活静物摄影师。所以这些照片都是他拍的。给曼迪拍的那组照片是让她穿着一件肉色的抹胸拍的。
Like a tube top. Yes, because they knew that it would be pixelated later in post. So that's how we did it. You know, I'm gonna bring out this story. I wasn't planning on it, but this episode feels like, I don't know, it feels like it would be on theme. I wrote about this in my book, The Actor's Life, A Survival Guide. The scene with Ryan showing Aaron the pictures of like Kelly Nude. Uh-huh. Have I ever told you the story of how I almost joined like an international spice girls singing group that was actually a front for a call girl service? What?
就像管状上衣一样。是的，因为他们知道后期会打马赛克。这就是我们完成拍摄的方式。你知道的，我要讲这个故事。我本来没打算讲，但这一集感觉，怎么说呢，感觉非常应景。我在我的书《演员的生活：生存指南》里写过这件事。瑞恩向艾琳展示凯莉裸照等照片的那场戏。嗯哼。我有没有给你讲过我差点加入一个国际辣妹歌唱组合的故事，而那个组合其实是一家高级应召女郎服务的幌子？什么？
Yeah. You thought you were auditioning to be in a band? Yeah. As singing group. That's how they hoodwinked the girls? Yeah. Ah! Yeah. I's how they hoodwinked the girls. Yeah. Yeah, I've also told this story on Conan. Oh my gosh. So I moved to LA and you know, you're just looking for any gig you can get. Sure. My friend was a really talented singer and she saw listing in the newspaper the free newspaper.
对。你以为你在试镜加入一个乐队？对。一个歌唱组合。他们就是这样忽悠女孩的？啊！对。这就是他们忽悠女孩的方式。对，我也在柯南的节目上讲过这个故事。哦天哪。所以我搬到了洛杉矶，你知道的，你就在寻找任何你能得到的工作。当然。我有个朋友是个非常有才华的歌手，她在免费报纸上看到了一个招聘广告。
Okay, red flag number one. Correct. Four, singing auditions for a new international spice girls type singing band in this guy's condo. Red flag number two. Yeah, audition in a condo, red flag two. She asked if I would go with her. I said, sure, I'll go with you. So I stood in line with her big group of people, went in, she sang,
好吧，第一个红旗警报。没错。在这个家伙的公寓里为一种类辣妹国际歌唱乐队进行歌唱试镜。第二个红旗警报。对，在一个公寓里试镜，第二个红旗警报。她问我能不能陪她一起去。我说，当然，我陪你去。于是我和她还有一大群人一起排队进去，她唱了歌，
and the guys like, do you sing to me? And I'm like, not really. No, he's like, well, just sing something. He's like, well, just sing something. So I sang Rocky Top. What? You know this song Rocky Top? Like good, oh, Rocky Top. Rocky Top, Tennessee. That's what Rocky Top, Tennessee. That's what came to my mind.
然后那家伙问我，你会为我唱歌吗？我说，其实不会。不，他说，那就随便唱点什么吧。他说，那就随便唱点什么吧。于是我唱了《落基山》。什么？你知道这首歌《落基山》吗？就像，哦，《落基山》。落基山，田纳西。就是那个，《落基山，田纳西》。这就是我脑子里想到的。
That's what came to my mind. So I sang Rocky Top. Guess what, lady? You got the part, you're in the band. You're in the band. I got it. With your Rocky Top song, I'm the American Girl.
这就是我脑子里想到的。所以我唱了《落基山》。你猜怎么着，女士？你被选上了，你加入乐队了。你加入乐队了。我被选上了。凭着你的《落基山》这首歌，我成了美国女孩。
Red flag number three. I get a call, it's me. Imagine my friend, my friend who's like a professional level singer. Yeah, she didn't get the gig. I got it. I'm gonna be the American Girl. This guy gives me a tape. I'm supposed to listen to it. I'm supposed to learn my song. It was a country song about a truck stop.
第三个红旗警报。我接到一个电话，是我。想象一下我的朋友，一个专业级别的歌手。是的，她没被选上。我被选上了。我要成为美国女孩了。这家伙给了我一盘磁带。我得听。我得学我的歌。那是一首关于卡车休息站的乡村歌曲。
I practiced it and practiced it and practiced it. And I was like, when do I meet the other girls in the group? He's like, soon, soon. Red flag. And then he calls me and he's like, listen, we have a gig coming up. I'm like, we have a gig coming up. I've never met the other girls in the group. How are we gonna do our dance moves? How are we gonna harmonize?
我练习了一遍又一遍，又一遍。然后我就想，我什么时候能见到组合里的其他女孩？他说，快了，快了。红旗警报。然后他打电话给我说，听着，我们有个演出要来。我说，我们有个演出？我从来没见过组合里的其他女孩。我们怎么排练舞蹈动作？我们怎么进行和声？
What are our outfits? And he's like, come by the condo. Red flag. And you know, let me just see how your song is doing. You'll just do your song. You'll do it just a solo. Oh my gosh, okay. Meanwhile, by the way, I've basically told everyone back in Missouri, buckle in. I'm about to be a big star. A huge pop star. So just I don't know if I'm going to be able to come home for thanks. Give me a chance.
我们的演出服是什么？他说，来公寓一趟吧。红旗警报。你知道的，让我看看你的歌练得怎么样了。你就唱你那首歌就行。你一个人独唱。哦天哪，好吧。顺便说一句，我已经把这事告诉了密苏里老家的所有人，系好安全带吧。我要成为大明星了。一个巨大的流行巨星。所以我不知道我感恩节还能不能回家。给我个机会。
I'm a sharn rocky top. I am now going to be a pop star. I had a whole new country name star for myself, Ginny Lee. My name was going to be Ginny Lee. Oh my god. You are giving me sh** about my journal, about like getting tooted at a party. You're Jenny Lee singing Rocky Top.
我唱着《落基山》。我现在要成为流行巨星了。我给自己起了一个全新的乡村歌手艺名，吉妮·莉。我的名字要叫吉妮·莉。哦天哪。你刚才还嘲笑我的日志，嘲笑我在派对上喝嗨了。你居然是叫吉妮·莉唱着《落基山》的人。
I am, so I go to the guys condo, and I've got my whole bit. I just wanna say that when I got there, there were girls walking around in lingerie. You guys, none of this is penetrating the stars in my eyes. None of this is like, I'm taking in none of this information. So I sing the song so earnestly.
我是，所以我去了那家伙的公寓，我带着我的一整套说辞。我只想说，当我到那儿的时候，看到有些女孩穿着内衣走来走去。伙计们，这些完全没有穿透我眼里的星星。这些完全没有让我意识到任何情况。所以我极其认真地唱着那首歌。
My truck stops on, gosh, I wish I still had the tape. Sing it and I'm like, how do you think? You're saying your country in Western song about a truck stop? Yeah, okay. I'm like, do you think I'm ready? He's like, I do, I do. Then he says to me, you know what you need
我的卡车休息站之歌，天哪，我真希望我手里还有那磁带。唱着歌，然后我问，你觉得怎么样？你还在唱你那首关于卡车休息站的乡村西部歌曲？对，好吧。我说，你觉得我准备好了吗？他说，我觉得可以，我觉得可以。然后他对我说，你知道你需要的是什么吗？
are some lingerie? Well, I guess I skipped the part where he offered to take my photo. Mm. He had mentioned that my headshots, Well, I guess I skipped the part where he offered to take my photo. He had mentioned that my headshots, they weren't very dazzling and he said that he takes headshots and he offered to take some new headshots for me. And I said, I can't afford that. He said, it's fine, you can pay me back later.
是一些内衣？好吧，我想我漏掉了他提出要给我拍照的那段。嗯。他曾提到我的头像照，好吧，我想我漏掉了他提出要给我拍照的那段。他曾提到我的头像照不够惊艳，并说他会拍头像照，还主动提出要帮我拍一些新的头像照。我说，我付不起那个钱。他说，没关系，你可以以后再还我。
And then he said, while we're doing it, why don't we take some of you in like a bikini or maybe nude? Because I'd like to represent you as an actress as well. And what if you go in on a part that requires nudity? You know, you don't wanna have to get nude in the room. It'd be better to just hand them a photo. Which never happens. Red flag.
然后他说，在我们拍的时候，为什么我们不拍一些你穿着比基尼甚至全裸的照片呢？因为我也想作为演员代理你。万一你去试镜一个需要裸露的角色怎么办？你知道的，你不会想在试镜房间里才临时脱衣服。最好直接递给他们一张照片。而这种事根本不会发生。红旗警报。
Red flag. But you know what my answer was? What? I was like, you know what? I'm not gonna wanna do parts with nudity so I won't need those photos. Again, why am I impenetrable? You're just sweet and innocent.
红旗警报。但你知道我的回答是什么吗？什么？我当时说，你知道吗？我才不想演有裸露镜头的角色，所以这些照片我用不上。再说一次，为什么我这么刀枪不入？你只是太单纯、太无辜了。
And this person is a monster. Okay, so what happened after you danced and sang your heart out about the truck stop? I said, am I ready? Do you think I should do the show on Friday? I'm so nervous! And he goes, I think you should. He goes, now here's the thing, I also want you to know
而这个人是个恶魔。好吧，在你又唱又跳地倾情演绎了卡车休息站之歌后，发生了什么？我说，我准备好了吗？你觉得我周五应该去演那场秀吗？我好紧张！他说，我觉得你应该去。他说，现在关键是，我还想让你知道
it's gonna be for a group of international businessmen. Moga. It's a private show. And afterwards, you know, if you wanna offer the gentleman some companionship, it can be quite lucrative. Here we go. This is when suddenly everything comes into focus for me.
这次演出是为一群国际商人准备的。哦。这是一场私人演出。演出结束后，你知道的，如果你想为主办的绅士们提供一些陪伴，报酬会相当丰厚。原来如此。这时我才突然看清了一切。
Suddenly I'm very aware of the people in lingerie. I'm very aware of the fact that I've never rehearsed with any of the other girls that offered to take nude photographs. The fact that my friend, who's an actual talented singer, didn't get the gig, I'm like, oh my God! This is a call girl ring! I'm not gonna be a famous pop star! And I left. I changed my phone numbers. I never spoke to him again. What did you tell everyone back in Missouri?
突然之间，我对那些穿着内衣的女孩有了清醒的认知。突然之间，我意识到我从来没有和任何其他女孩排练过，他提出要给我拍裸照。我的朋友明明是个真正有才华的歌手却没被选上，我心想，哦我的上帝！这是一个高级应召女郎团伙！我才不会成为什么当红流行巨星！然后我离开了。我换了手机号。我再也没有和他说过话。你对密苏里老家的所有人是怎么说的？
The truth. You did. I just did. I mean, what am I going to do? I told my parents. I get where they like get on a plane home. How did my parents not fly out and bring me home? I don't know. That was a very long tangent, but it sprung to mind when Ryan was like, I could take photos of you. Creeper. Creeper. So guys, if you're an aspiring actor and you want to come to Los Angeles or New York, maybe by my book, the actor's life a survival guide where I lay out a lot of things that you shouldn't Experience. While this photo display is happening, Pam's mom walks in. Yes, and we're gonna have a little bit of Angela's ass coming up. Oh, yeah. Pam, aren't you going to introduce us to Michael's girlfriend? Angela Martin, enjoy saying that so much. I know.
实话实说。你居然说了。我就是说了。不然我能怎么办？我告诉了我爸妈。真不明白他们怎么没坐飞机来接我回家。不知道。这真是一个超级长的题外话，但当瑞恩说“我可以给你拍照”时，这个记忆就涌上心头了。变态。变态。所以各位，如果你是一个有抱负的演员，想要来洛杉矶或纽约，也许可以买我的书《演员的生活：生存指南》，我在里面列出了许多你不应该经历的事情。在这个摄影展进行的同时，帕姆的妈妈走了进来。是的，接下来我们要看到安吉拉的屁股出场了。哦，是的。帕姆，你难道不打算把我们介绍给迈克尔的女友吗？安吉拉·马丁，太喜欢说这句话了。我知道。
How about the story about the necklace that Michael slipped onto Helene's neck this morning? While she was sleeping, Kelly's like it's beautiful. No, it's not. I loved that. I'm gonna break down all the gifts that Helene got in a little bit. Oh, so remember the necklace. We got a piece of mail from Genevieve B
迈克尔今天早上套在海伦脖子上的那条项链的故事怎么样？趁她睡着的时候，凯莉说太漂亮了。不，才不漂亮。我太喜欢那个了。我一会儿要把海伦收到的所有礼物都盘点一遍。哦，还记得那条项链吗。我们收到了来自内布拉斯加州奥马哈的詹妮维夫·B
in Omaha, Nebraska. Who said this? I found this fascinating. I worked as a manager for Clare's in the late Aught's early 2010s, and I am 90% sure that Helene's necklace was from the Icing's Dressy Special Occasion collection. Clare's boutique in the mall? Yeah, that's where I got my ears pierced.
发来的邮件。她说了什么？我觉得这太迷人了。我在2000年代末到2010年代初曾担任克莱尔饰品店的经理，我有90%的把握确信海伦的这条项链来自 Icing 的盛装特殊场合系列。商场里的克莱尔饰品店？对，我就是在那儿打的耳洞。
Me too. Really? Yeah. Oh my gosh. It's still where you get my ears pierced. Me too. Really? Yeah. Oh my gosh. It's still where you get your ears pierced. Yeah. It's what they're known for. Genevieve goes on to say,
我也是。真的吗？对。哦天哪。那也是你打耳洞的地方。我也是。真的吗？对。哦天哪。那也是你打耳洞的地方。对。那就是他们出名的原因。詹妮维夫接着说道，
if so, the piece in question appears to be a Kubrick's Arconian necklace. And in 2009, 2010-ish, they were marked down to $5. Okay. I'm not sure where we got this necklace, but I think this is a good guess. I think it's a great catch.
如果是这样的话，这件首饰似乎是一条库布里克斯·阿尔科尼安项链。而在2009、2010年前后，它们降价到了5美元。好吧。我不太确定我们是从哪弄来这条项链的，但我认为这是一个很好的猜测。我觉得这是一个绝妙的发现。
Well, Pam's gonna try to get out of going to lunch by having Aaron transfer a fakey phone call. This was very funny to me, along with Creed's talking head. I thought all of it was really funny. I also loved John's performances, Jim, where he's like, nope, hardly ever. He like hangs up.
好吧，帕姆打算让艾琳转接一个假电话来逃避去吃午饭。这让我觉得非常搞笑，还有克里德的单人访谈。我觉得所有这些都太搞笑了。我也很喜欢约翰的表演，吉姆，他当时说，不，几乎没有。他直接挂断了电话。
Also he doesn't say anything. Like when he's like, I'll handle it. He takes the phone and he goes, okay, great. Yeah. It's there. They found it. And then Creed's worried. He's like, that paper was never supposed to arrive.
而且他什么都没说。比如当他说，我来处理。他拿起电话说，好的，太棒了。对。找到了。然后克里德很担心。他说，那份文件根本就不该寄到。
What is Creed running on the side? I don't know. Is Creed the reason they're going bankrupt? I think so. Probably. Pam doesn't get out of it. She's got to go to this birthday, double date. The car ride was so cringey.
克里德私底下到底在搞什么鬼？我不知道。难道克里德才是他们公司濒临破产的原因？我觉得是的。很可能。帕姆没能逃掉。她不得不去参加这个生日双重约会。车上的气氛太尴尬了。
But guess what? The car ride home's going to be even worse. Pam's mom calls her Pammy. Did you notice? I did notice and it's like Colleen and Michael are like talking to Pam about making good choices and being a good salesperson and they're being so parental. And you can just see like Pam is like,
但你猜怎么着？回程的车里会更糟糕。帕姆的妈妈叫她“帕米”。你注意到了吗？我注意到了，而且海伦和迈克尔就像在对帕姆说教，教她如何做出正确的选择、如何成为一个优秀的销售员，他们表现得就像父母一样。你可以看出帕姆当时的心情是，
oh my God, what is happening? So next we're gonna go into the kitchen and Dwight is continuing his favors for the office. He's cleaning out the freezer. Oh, I have some catches here. Oh, tell. Four minutes, 42 seconds. Did you guys see what all Dwight had taken out of the freezer and put on the counter? I did. I paused it. Took a screen grab. Let's see if we clocked the same stuff. Seven tubs of ice cream.
哦天哪，这都什么事啊。接下来我们要去厨房，德怀特继续在办公室里执行他的人情计划。他在清理冷冻柜。哦，我这里有一些发现。哦，快说。4分钟42秒。大家看到德怀特从冷冻柜里拿出来摆在台面上的都有什么了吗？看到了。我按了暂停。截了屏。来看看我们记录的是不是一样。七桶冰淇淋。
Seven tubs of ice cream, all of which still have the plastic thing on them. Like none of them have been opened. Yeah. Six frozen microwave dinners. Mm-hmm. Some mixed veggies. Mm-hmm.
七桶冰淇淋，上面居然都还带着塑料封口。就像压根没开封过一样。嗯哼。六盒冷冻微波炉快餐。嗯哼。一些混合蔬菜。嗯哼。
A whole thing of butter. A bag of, what is that? Six small baguettes. Yes. And then two enormous bags of what looks like to be raw chicken sitting on top of the microwave, which will get called back later. So much raw chicken. We had a fan question from Hepsy, from Kornavaka, Mexico. I noticed white cleaning the fridge in this scene and I'm wondering if you guys ever used the fridge or freezer or cabinets to actually store your real snacks. We did not. It was just props. We never ate any of that. We never kept our food in there. There was well, what? Sometimes Mindy would eat prop food. We know. Mindy and Ed were notorious for eating prop food.
一整块黄油。一袋，那是什么？六个小法式长棍面包。然后还有两袋巨大的、看起来像是生鸡肉的东西放在微波炉上面，这在后面还会呼应。好多的生鸡肉。我们收到了来自墨西哥库埃纳瓦卡的海普西的粉丝提问：我注意到德怀特在这场戏里清理冰箱，我想知道你们是否曾经用过冰箱、冷冻柜或橱柜来真正存放你们自己的零食？我们没有。那只是道具。我们从来没吃过那些东西。我们从来不在里面放自己的食物。有，嗯，什么？有时曼迪会吃道具食物。我们知道的。曼迪和埃德是出了名的爱吃道具食物。
But we kept all of our snacks in our desk drawer. Yes, my perishable snacks, we kept in the fridge that was backstage. Yeah. But I had like a bag of potato chips and a drawer. Oh yeah. Oh yeah. I had a gum.
但我们把所有的零食都放在办公桌抽屉里。对，我的易腐烂零食，我们放在后台的冰箱里。对。不过我在抽屉里放了一袋薯片。哦对。哦对。我放了口香糖。
Yeah. But I would never, I would not trust eating something I found in that fridge. Because maybe it was from like, who knows when? Oh, yeah. Unless it was a new item made for that episode, the other stuff in there just sort of stayed. I remember one time, a few of us,
对。但我绝对不会，我绝不敢吃我在那个冰箱里找到的东西。因为天知道那是从什么时候开始的？哦，对。除非那是为那一集新制作的物品，否则里面的其他东西基本上就一直搁在那儿。我记得有一次，我们几个，
I don't know why ate some of those cheese balls. Oh yeah, I was there, I was part of that. It was like a dare near the end. And all of a sudden I remember feel-shaving like guys, guys, we spray those with the stuff so they don't go bad. We're like, ugh. Yeah, with like a lacquer. You know, we're fine. We're here.
不知道为什么吃了一些那些奶酪球。哦对，我在，我当时也是其中之一。那是快结束时的一次大冒险。然后我突然记得菲尔·谢说，伙计们，伙计们，我们在那些上面喷了特殊药水，所以它们不会变质。我们当时想，呃。对，就像喷了一层清漆。你知道的，我们没事。我们挺过来了。
Well, while Dwight's cleaning out the freezer, Andy comes in to give him his newly polished briefcase because he's returning the favor of the bagels. And this leads to this favor competition, basically, as they're walking back to their desks. It's really funny. These two guys cracked me up. Me too. You know, at five minutes, 36 seconds, Dwight says,
好吧，正当德怀特在清理冷冻柜时，安迪进来送他刚刚擦得锃亮的公文包，因为他要还百吉饼的人情。这导致他们在走回办公桌的路上展开了一场“人情竞赛”。真的太搞笑了。这两个家伙把我逗乐了。我也是。你知道的，在5分钟36秒的时候，德怀特说，
if you clench your buttocks together while walking, you can really take the pressure off your knees. Little tip there, just a little tip. Well, I looked it up. Does it work? I was gonna try it. Well, I read an article called Getting to the Bottom of Knee Pain in Women.
如果你在走路时把屁股紧紧夹在一起，就能大大减轻膝盖的压力。给个小贴士，就这么个小贴士。好吧，我查了一下。有用吗？我本想试试的。好吧，我读了一篇名为《探究女性膝盖疼痛之源》的文章。
Oh, okay. Knee pain in women caused by their but's question mark, the article asks, it says, if you're experiencing knee pain and you go to a physical therapist, they might ask you, are you using your butt? If the pain is not from like an obvious injury, you know, this physical therapist says I always start with the glutes. I guess a lot of times knee pain can be caused by either tight weak hips or weak glutes because the glutes are like your stabilizer.
哦，好吧。女性膝盖疼痛是由她们的臀部引起的吗？文章问道，如果你正经历膝盖疼痛并且去看理疗师，他们可能会问你，你用屁股发力了吗？如果疼痛不是由明显的受伤引起的，你知道的，这位理疗师说我通常从臀肌开始。我猜很多时候膝盖疼痛可能是由紧绷虚弱的髋部或虚弱的臀肌引起的，因为臀肌就像是你的稳定器。
And so they will often want you to increase your glutes. But the question here is if you're supposed to clench your buttocks or not. When you walk. And so while yes, weak glutes could be the root of your knee problem, I read a different article called to clench or not to clench your butt. That is the question by Brooke Thomas. She says, do not permaclench your butt, that is the question by Brooke Thomas. She says, do not permaclench your butt. Don't permaclench it.
所以他们通常会希望你锻炼臀肌。但这里的问题是你走路时到底应不应该夹紧屁股。所以，虽然虚弱的臀肌确实可能是你膝盖问题的根源，但我读了另一篇名为《要不要夹紧你的屁股，这是个问题》的文章，作者是布鲁克·托马斯。她说，千万不要长期夹紧你的屁股，这是布鲁克·托马斯提出的问题。她说，千万不要长期夹紧屁股。不要一直夹紧它。
What's a permaclench? That's, I think, where you're just clenching for no reason. Why would you clench for no reason? To take the pressure off your knees. Oh! She said it can lead to other problems. It can lead to wear and tear on your lumbar discs. You can get too tight of a pelvic floor.
什么是长期夹紧？那就是，我想，毫无理由地一直紧绷着。你为什么要毫无理由地夹紧呢？为了减轻膝盖压力。哦！她说这会导致其他问题。这会导致腰椎磨损。还会导致盆底肌过于紧绷。
I guess that's bad. Instead of clenching, just do good glute workouts to build up the whole muscle. Okay. Okay. I know that we have not gotten very far into this episode. Should we take a break though? And then we'll come back and we'll break down the rest. Yeah, because when we come back, the Scott family
我想那挺糟糕的。与其紧绷着，不如好好做臀部锻炼来锻炼整个肌肉。好的。好的。我知道我们这集内容还没讲多少。不过我们要不要休息一下？然后再回来继续剖析剩下的部分。行，因为当我们回来时，斯科特一家
is checking in at the restaurant. Yes. [♪ OUTRO MUSIC PLAYING [♪ Scott family table is ready. But which one is it? I mean, there's just a bunch of boring tables. Yeah. Oh wait, one has a ton of balloons.
正在餐厅登记入住。没错。[♪ 片尾音乐响起 [♪ 斯科特一家的桌子准备好了。但到底是哪一张？我是说，这只是一堆无聊的桌子。好吧。哦等等，其中一张有一大堆气球。
And um, nice of the restaurant to let them hang a banner in their potted plants. I know. It is so sweet. Michael has completely decorated this table for Helene's birthday. Pam notices, I think this is the first moment where she's kind of softening to this. Also because Helene is so delighted. She's so happy. They start the birthday lunch, sort of talking about how like, oh, they're at this great Italian restaurant. Michael's like, you know, I'd love to go to Italy. Helene's like, oh, you can have all my travel books. I, you know, I can't do those big trips anymore.
还有，嗯，餐厅真好，让他们把横幅挂在盆栽植物上。我懂。真是太贴心了。迈克尔为海伦的生日把这张桌子完全装饰了一番。潘注意到了，我想这是她第一次对这件事有点心软。也是因为海伦太高兴了。她太快乐了。他们开始生日午餐，聊到他们在这家很棒的意大利餐厅。迈克尔说，你知道的，我很想去意大利。海伦说，哦，你可以把我所有的旅行书都拿去。我，你知道的，我再也经不起那种长途旅行了。
Yeah, the flights are too long. Yeah, not interested. And he's like, great, I guess I'll take your books. And then, Pam and her mom have this like fun little banter. Pam's like, so mom, which birthday are we celebrating this year? Jenna, I used to do this with my mom. What do you mean? I would be like, okay, mom, what birthday is it?
对，航班太长了。对，没兴趣。然后他说，太好了，我想我会收下你的书。接着，潘和她妈妈有了一段这样有趣的小玩笑。潘说，那么妈妈，我们今年庆祝的是第几个生日？珍娜，我以前经常跟我妈这样。什么意思？我会说，好吧，妈妈，到底是几岁？
And for years, my mom said 32. Really? 32. That is so funny. So, Haleen says, I'm sticking with 49. Pam says 49 again. That's nine years in a row. Michael's like, aha, that's funny, but you can see him trying to do the math.
多年来，我妈一直说32岁。真的吗？32岁。太搞笑了。所以，海伦说，我坚持49岁。潘说又49岁。连续九年了。迈克尔就像是，啊哈，这很有趣，但你可以看到他在努力算数。
But then he's going to need to take pencil to paper. And still get it wrong. Right. Michael realizes that Helene is 58. And you can tell this hits him. Pretty hard. We had a fan catch though from Alison H and Louisville Kentucky, and many others, by the way. Who said, I think there's a math error.
但接下来他得拿纸笔来算。而且还是会算错。对。迈克尔意识到海伦58岁了。你可以看出这对他的打击。挺大的。不过我们收到了来自肯塔基州路易斯维尔的艾莉森·H以及顺便说一句许多其他人的粉丝爆料。有位粉丝说，我觉得这里有个数学错误。
Helene says she's 49. Pam says it's the ninth year in a row, but if she first celebrated her 49th birthday on her 49th birthday, that counts as one of the nine. So you would actually add 49 plus eight additional birthdays, which means Celine is really turning 57. Nice catch.
海伦说她49岁，潘说是连续第九年，但如果她第一次庆祝49岁生日是在她49岁生日那天，那就算作九次中的一次。所以你实际上应该加上49再加上额外的八个生日，这意味着海伦实际上是要满57岁。好发现。
Yeah. So when I was trading messages with Charlie Grandy about this episode, he said that what he remembers most about working with Seth Gordon was the fact that me, John, Steve,, we're going to be locked at this same table for like four big scenes in a row. And it became this big question, how are we going to visually differentiate these scenes? How are we going to make them feel alive? Right. And Charlie said, if you rewatch it, you can really see what a great job he did.
对。所以当我跟查理·格兰迪就这一集互发消息时，他说他关于跟赛斯·戈登合作最深刻的记忆是，我和约翰、史蒂夫，我们将在同一张桌子上被锁死大约四个连场的大戏。这就成了一个巨大的问题，我们要如何在视觉上区分这些场景？我们要如何让它们显得充满活力？没错。查理说，如果你重看一遍，你真的能看出他做得多棒。
He added multiple angles, he keeps flipping sides to keep it interesting. And by mostly framing out the other tables, he does a great job of shrinking what was a really big space. And quote, imprisoning you in Michael's awkwardness. Oh, that's so artsy. I know. And it's really true. I started rewatching these scenes. And we only use two cameras, but in each of the scenes, they set them up a little differently. So you didn't feel like you were coming back to the same table. And as the scenes go on, the camera gets closer and closer and closer. So you really are like going into Michael's little mind. It's cool.
他增加了多个角度，不断转换拍摄方向来保持趣味性。通过大部分把其他桌子移出取景框，他在缩小原本很大的空间方面做得非常出色，并且“引述：将你禁锢在迈克尔的尴尬之中。”哦，太文艺了。我知道。而且真的没错。我开始重看这些场景。我们只用了两台摄像机，但在每个场景中，它们的布置都略有不同。所以你不会觉得你回到了同一张桌子。随着场景的发展，摄像机靠得越来越近。所以你真的就像是进入了迈克尔的小脑瓜里。这很酷。
It's really cool. Well, we're going to go from this talk of being 49, nine years in a row, but actually being 58 with more sexy talk. What name should she be called, Nana or Grandma? Michael's really feeling it now. He is. I noticed something at nine minutes and six seconds in the scene. What? Do you notice how Steve eats his food as Michael Scott? It's exactly how he ate in dinner party. Well, he kind of scrapes the fork with his teeth. Yes, he eats tiny amounts of food off the tip of the fork with his very front teeth. He doesn't put the fork all the way in his mouth.
真的很酷。好吧，我们要从这种连续九年说自己49岁，但实际上58岁的话题，过渡到更多性感的谈话。她应该叫什么名字，娜娜还是奶奶？迈克尔现在真的很有感觉。他是的。我在九分六秒的场景里注意到了一件事。什么？你注意到史蒂夫作为迈克尔·斯科特是怎么吃东西的吗？这跟他当初在晚宴派对上的吃相一模一样。好吧，他有点用牙齿刮叉子。是的，他用最前面的牙齿从叉子尖吃极少量的食物。他不会把叉子整个放进嘴里。
He like bites it off the tip of the fork. It's very interesting. He does not eat this way in real life. I've dined with him many times. This is clearly a Michael Scott eating choice. It's either a Michael Scott eating choice or it's Steve the actor not wanting to eat the prop food and making the best of it. Because I would do something similar. I would just put the tiniest amount like on the end of the fork or spoon. So I didn't have to eat too much of it. Well, now I guess I'd have to watch Steve's other films
他就像是从叉子尖上咬下来。非常有趣。他在现实生活中可不这样吃。我和他共进过很多次晚餐。这显然是迈克尔·斯科特的吃法选择。这要么是迈克尔·斯科特的吃法选择，要么是演员史蒂夫不想吃道具食物，从而将就着做。因为我也会做类似的事。我只会把极少量的东西放在叉子或勺子的尖端。这样我就不用吃太多了。好吧，现在我想我得去看史蒂夫的其他电影
and see if he's eating in any of them and see if this is just his actor way of eating or if it was a character choice, I'll investigate. Investigate, because with prop food, when you start out, it's usually really fresh and warm and they've made it ready for you to eat, but as each take goes, it gets colder and colder and a little bit more wilty depending what you're eating and I just found early on
看看他在其中有没有吃东西，看看这只是他作为演员的吃法，还是角色的选择，我去调查一下。去调查吧，因为对于道具食物来说，刚开始时通常真的很新鲜、很热，而且是为你准备好食用的，但随着每一次拍摄，它会变得越来越冷，越来越枯萎，这取决于你在吃什么，我早就发现
The smaller bites are better true It's also lunchtime back at Dunderclund and oh my gosh Andy has set up a whole taco buffet in the conference room Yes, but Dwight is going to volunteer to serve everyone. Yes. Did you notice at nine minutes, 26 seconds when Angela Martin enters? Yes. Her face she makes and she does a 180 out of the room. Well, because she's vegetarian.
小口一点更好，确实如此。邓德米夫林办公室的午餐时间也到了，哦天哪，安迪在会议室里布置了整整一塔可自助餐！是的，但德怀特自告奋勇要为每个人服务。是的。你有没有注意到九分二十六秒安洁莉娜·马丁进来的时候？是的。她做出的那个表情，然后180度转身走出了房间。哦，因为她是素食主义者。
So I went to the script because I was like, what did it say in the script about this moment? In the script, it just says Angela Martin enters the room and immediately walks back out. Oh, so the room and immediately walks back out. Oh! So the face I made was just me, like probably playing around in the moment. I have a question. Did you guys actually eat those tacos that day? They looked good. We did not just because it had to sit there for a bit. Oh. But we wanted to when they first brought them out, we're like, woohoo tacos and like, like, no, no, no, guys, there's also a Kevin talking head and little moment that got
所以我去查了剧本，因为我在想，剧本里对这个时刻是怎么写的？在剧本里，只写着安洁莉娜·马丁走进房间然后立刻又走了出去。哦，所以房间里然后立刻又走了出去。哦！所以我做的那个表情只是我自己在那个时刻大概在即兴发挥。我有个问题。那天你们真的吃了那些塔可吗？看起来很好吃。我们没有吃，只是因为它们得在那放一会儿。哦。但刚拿出来时我们很想吃，我们就像是，呜呼塔可，然后，不不不，伙计们，还有一个凯文的单人访谈和小片段
deleted probably for time. I loved it. Kevin is so excited that Dwight is going to serve the tacos. And he has this talking head. This is great. I love tacos. But whenever I try to make one, I get too excited and I crush it. And! And so then it cuts back to the scene and Dwight's making his taco. Dwight hands it to Kevin and Kevin so excited he crushes it in his hand. Oh! Kevin! Well, after these guys compete to see who's going to serve the tacos, now they're going to compete to see who's going to clean them up. It doesn't stop.
大概因为时长被删减了。我很喜欢。凯文超级兴奋德怀特要来端塔可。他有这样一个单人访谈。这太棒了。我喜欢塔可。但每当我试图做一个时，我就会太兴奋然后把它捏碎。然后！然后镜头切回场景，德怀特正在做他的塔可。德怀特把它递给凯文，凯文太兴奋了，在手里把它捏碎了。哦！凯文！好吧，在这几个人争夺谁来端塔可之后，现在他们要争夺谁来清理它们。这还没完。
It doesn't stop. Do you know what I'd like to break down all the gifts that Michael got, Haleen. Oh, and really show how all-out he went for her until he broke up with her. He went all-out. He got hurt, the necklace, and then also the lunch reservation, right?
没完没了。你知道我想剖析迈克尔送给海伦的所有礼物吗。哦，并且真正展示他是如何为她倾尽所有，直到跟她分手。他全力以赴了。他受伤了，那条项链，还有午餐预订，对吧？
Where he decorated the table, I counted eight balloons, a birthday banner, and also a really beautiful flower arrangement that none of the other tables had. Yes. I assume she can take that with her. Yes. As well as a scrapbook of their courtship, the wrapping paper says love in several different languages. Here are a few things that were in the scrapbook. Per the shooting draft, some made it in the episode, some did not. Oh! The penny that Haleen threw into the wishing well at the mall. Which doesn't exist. Right. The fountain that doesn't exist.
他在那里布置了桌子，我数了八个气球、一个生日横幅，还有一个其他桌子都没有的非常漂亮的花艺。是的。我猜她可以把它带走。是的，还有他们求爱过程的纪念册，包装纸上用几种不同的语言写着爱。以下是纪念册里的一些东西。根据拍摄初稿，有些被剪进了剧集，有些没有。哦！海伦在商场的许愿池里扔的那枚硬币。根本不存在。没错。那个不存在的喷泉。
Also, a ticket stub to a movie they went to together, Love Happens. Oh! I looked up Love Happens. It was a movie that was out in 2009, starring Jennifer Amiston and Aaron Eckhart, as well as the poem that Michael wrote slash plagiarized from Shell Silverstein. Hmm, here was the poem. I cannot go to school today, said little Peggy Ann McKay. I have the measles and the mumps, a gash, a rash,
还有，他们一起去看的一部电影的电影票根，《爱不宜迟》。哦！我查了《爱不宜迟》。那是2009年上映的一部电影，由詹妮弗·安妮斯顿和亚伦·艾克哈特主演，还有迈克尔写给或抄袭自谢尔·西尔弗斯坦的诗。嗯，诗是这样的。我今天不能去上学，小佩吉·安·麦凯说。我得了麻疹和腮腺炎，有一道口子、皮疹，
and purple bumps. My teachers really mean happy birthday. I love you, Halene. I mean, it's beautiful. It might be in my journal. We had a fan question about this scrapbook from Carla B. in Gardina, California. The cover page of the scrapbook at the very bottom where it says love copyright Michael. bottom where it says, love, copyright, Michael. We also see the letters,
还有紫色的肿块。我的老师真的很想祝你生日快乐。我爱你，海伦。我是说，这太美了。它可能会出现在我的日记里。我们收到了加利福尼亚州加迪纳的卡拉·B关于这本纪念册的粉丝提问。纪念册的封面最底部写着“爱，版权所有，迈克尔”。底部写着“爱，版权所有，迈克尔”。我们还看到了这些字母，
X, X, L, R. Any idea what those letters stand for? Do you know, Ange? I do. What is it? It's in the shooting draft. Oh, tell us, because I thought they were Roman numerals,
X，X，L，R。知道这些字母代表什么吗？你知道吗，安吉？我知道。是什么？在拍摄初稿里。哦，快告诉我们，因为我以为那是罗马数字，
but when I looked it up, there's no R in Roman numerals. Yes. So, Haleen reads that out loud, kind of like curious and Michael goes, those are Roman numerals I made. So, Haleen reads that out loud, kind of like curious and Michael goes, those are Roman numerals I made them up. Oh my gosh! I did not know that you knew the answer to that question
但当我查的时候，罗马数字里没有R。对。所以，海伦大声读了出来，有点好奇的样子，然后迈克尔说，那些是我捏造的罗马数字。所以，海伦大声读了出来，有点好奇的样子，然后迈克尔说，那些是我捏造的罗马数字。哦天哪！我不知道你竟然知道那个问题的答案
when I asked it. Yeah, it's in the shooting draft. Oh, the shooting draft it unlocks so many mysteries. So many mysteries. I have a few other things to share from the shooting draft as well. Did you notice that Jim and Pam left under Mifflin with a box, a gift box wrapped in green wrapping paper? Jim is carrying it. Oh, yes,
当我问的时候。对，在拍摄初稿里。哦，拍摄初稿解开了好多谜团。好多谜团。我还有其他一些东西要从拍摄初稿里分享。你注意到吉姆和潘带着一个用绿色包装纸包裹的礼品盒离开邓德米夫林了吗？吉姆正拿着它。哦，是的，
yes. Yes. And they bring it in to the restaurant. It's their gift to Helene. Oh, do you know what they got? Helene. What? And the shooting draft, it says, Helene is holding a sweater that Jim and Pam gave her. Michael. What a nice gift. Oh, yes, a cozy sweater on his 58-year-old girlfriend. It's not sexy. It's not sexy to him. I mean, Michael is really spiraling. So much so that he's going to go hide. Pam has to go find him.
是的。是的，他们把它带进了餐厅。那是他们送给海伦的礼物。哦，你知道他们送了什么吗？海伦。什么？在拍摄初稿里，上面写着，海伦手里拿着一张吉姆和潘送给她的毛衣。迈克尔。多好的礼物啊。哦，是的，在他58岁女朋友身上的舒适毛衣。这可不性感。这对他来说不性感。我是说，迈克尔真的在失控。以至于他要去躲起来。潘不得不去找他。
He's like hiding in the bar. Yeah, she's like, come on, weirdo. It's time for cake. This scene was amazing start to finish. The fact that it starts off with Michael saying, finish your cake, Halene. I want you to enjoy that cake because I have something terrible I need to tell you.
他就像是在酒吧里躲着。对，她说，得了吧，怪胎。该吃蛋糕了。这个场景从头到尾都太棒了。它以迈克尔说的话开场：吃完你的蛋糕，海伦。我希望你好好享受那个蛋糕，因为我有件可怕的事必须告诉你。
Yeah, how did you get through that without laughing? First of all, the thing that made us laugh the most was the waitress interrupting us to pour the water. That was so brilliant. I thought that was brilliant. It is scripted exactly in the shooting draft the way you guys shot it. Yeah. Because this is what you really do.
对，你是怎么忍住不笑场拍完这一段的？首先，最让我们笑场的是女服务员打断我们去倒水。那太绝了。我觉得那太绝了。拍摄初稿里的剧本就是完全按照你们拍摄的那样写的。对。因为这就是你现实中会做的事。
You have these conversations and sometimes someone walks up to your table and you have to stop mid-sentence. Yes, I do it all the time. All the time. What is that like from the waiter's point of view? I mean, you know I walked in a restaurant. You know people like you walk up. Sometimes you hear stuff. Sometimes they don't stop. But this was hilarious. Michael is saying how he wants kids. And you, any gestures to Helene, unfortunately, have already completed that part of your journey down there. Pam's like Michael. Michael's like, Hey, it's not my decision. It's Mother Nature. And Mother has very strict rules about fur. Tilted. It was so difficult to get through. I would have completely lost it.
你有这些对话，有时有人走到你的桌子旁，你不得不话说到一半停下来。是的，我经常这么做。一直如此。从服务员的角度来看那是怎样的？我是说，你知道我走进了餐厅。你知道人们像你一样走过去。有时你会听到一些东西。有时他们不会停下来。但这太搞笑了。迈克尔在说他多么想要孩子。而你，任何对海伦的姿态，不幸的是，已经完成了你那段人生旅程的那个部分。潘就像是，迈克尔。迈克尔就像是，嘿，这不是我能决定的。这是大自然母亲。而母亲对毛发有非常严格的规则。倾斜。太难熬过去了。我早就彻底崩溃了。
So Michael's clearly breaking up with Helene, and he uses Pam as the excuse. He's like, you know I've thought about it. This isn't fair to Pam. Pam's like, no, no, no, Michael. Jenna, there was a talking head that would have come here. It was in the shooting draft. It got deleted, and it really showed what Pam was feeling. I'm going to read it to you.
所以迈克尔显然是要和海伦分手，他把潘当作借口。他说，你知道我考虑过了。这对潘不公平。潘说，不，不，不，迈克尔。珍娜，这里本该有一个单人访谈。它在拍摄初稿里。被删掉了，它真正展现了潘的感受。我读给你听。
Okay. My mom used to call me every night to cry about the divorce. Then she started dating Michael and she stopped calling. And I thought it was because she knew how mad I was. But now I think it was because she stopped crying. And that's what I should want for her, right? Mmm. And so you would have had that talking head and then you would have cut back to the scene when Pam's like, you know what, no, Michael, it's, it's okay. It took me a while to come around to it, but I'm okay with it. I'm glad they cut that talking head. Because I think that makes you kind of really hate Michael for breaking up with her because I don't know. It's so, it's so pure, it's so sweet. Yeah.
好的。我妈以前每天晚上都给我打电话哭诉离婚的事。然后她开始跟迈克尔约会，她就不打电话了。我以为是因为她知道我有多生气。但现在我觉得是因为她不哭了。而这应该是我希望她拥有的，对吧？嗯。所以你本会有那个单人访谈，然后镜头会切回场景，当时潘说，你知道吗，不，迈克尔，这，没关系。我花了好一会儿才接受，但我没关系。我很高兴他们删掉了那个单人访谈。因为我觉得那会让你有点真的很恨迈克尔跟他分手，因为我不知道。它太纯粹了，太甜了。对。
You know, and it just really breaks your heart for Haleen. Too much, too much. Yes. Before we move on, I just want to say the cake was really good. Oh, I wondered about that. It brought back memories. Well, Michael's going to tell Haleen there is another woman and her name is Italy and skydiving and bungee jumping and Then Jenna Michael decides that he's gonna also try to comfort her in this moment
你知道，这真的让人为海伦感到心碎。太多了，太多了。是的。在我们继续之前，我只想说那块蛋糕真的很好吃。哦，我还在想这个呢。它勾起了回忆。好吧，迈克尔要告诉海伦有另一个女人，她的名字叫意大利，还有跳伞和蹦极，然后珍娜，迈克尔决定他要在这一刻也试着安慰她
It's in the deleted scenes. We have to hear it. It's like You don't buy a madlib's book with everything already written in it. You're gonna find somebody so quickly with your killer bod and your wisdom. God! Ow! Somebody kicked. Did you guys get kicked? Nope. I kicked you to stop. Kicks Michael really hard.
在被删减的场景里。我们必须听听。就像你不会买一本已经写好所有内容的疯狂填词书。你会凭着你那杀手般的身材和智慧，很快找到另一个人的。天哪！哎哟！有人踢了。你们被踢了吗？没有。我踢你是为了阻止。狠狠地踢了迈克尔。
It is so funny. And I think I almost see you start to break. I remember filming those now. It was really funny. Yeah. So Michael is like, what? What? And Jim just shut some down. And this leads us to the super cringy car right home. Yeah. Helene is wondering out loud, what is she going to do now? She's 58 and single. And Michael's like, how about hobbies? Jim's like, no. No.
太搞笑了。而且我觉得我几乎看到你开始笑场了。我现在回想起来拍摄那时候。真的很好笑。对。所以迈克尔就说，什么？什么？吉姆直接让他们闭嘴。这就引出了那段让人极度尴尬的回家车程。 yeah。海伦在大声纳闷，她现在该怎么办？她58岁还单身。迈克尔就像是，要不培养点爱好？吉姆就像是，不。不。
This scene continued on. Helene says, why do I keep dating these losers? But she doesn't stop there. You have to hear it. What is it about me that makes me choose these loser guys? I don't know if I'd say you want to stay. I'm totally in the station. Do you know how long it's been since I've had an orgasm?
这个场景还在继续。海伦说，为什么我一直在跟这些Loser约会？但她还没停下来。你必须听听。我身上到底有什么让我总是挑中这些Loser男？我不知道该不该说你想留下来。我完全在状态。你知道我有多久没过高潮了吗？
Years. She told me she doesn't like him. Oh my God! Is that so funny? I mean how awkward is that car ride for Pam? Oh my gosh. I mean, Pam has had to hear so much today. So much. Maybe she already knew. I mean, it sounds like they're close but I
好几年了。她告诉我她不喜欢他。哦天哪！是不是超级搞笑？我是说，对潘来说那车程有多尴尬？哦天哪！我是说，潘今天已经不得不听了太多了。太多了。也许她已经知道了。我是说，听起来他们很亲近，但我
don't know I think there's new information. Oh yeah. Oh yeah. Well they get back to the office and first of all we see Andy trying to get something from a real tall shelf. He can't get it Dwight can you help me? Dwight's so excited! Here it is! Andy needs him! It's a favor! Guess what it is. Starbucks gift card. From everyone! Were you curious how Andy got the whole group to chip in for a gift card for Dwight? A little. I was, so I went to the shooting draft. Does it tell all? It tells all! And I'm going to share it with you. Dwight goes to the restroom. And when he does, Andy gets up and makes an announcement to the bullpen. He says, maybe you noticed Dwight has been trying real hard to do nice things for us. That's not his normal way.
不知道，我觉得有新信息。哦，对。哦，对。他们回到办公室，首先我们看到安迪试图从一个很高的架子上拿东西。他拿不到，德怀特，你能帮帮我吗？德怀特太兴奋了！给！安迪需要他！这是一个忙！你猜是什么。星巴克礼品卡。大家送的！你好奇安迪是怎么让整组人出钱给德怀特买礼品卡的吗？有点好奇。我也好奇，所以我去看了拍摄剧本。上面全写着吗？全写着！我要跟你们分享。德怀特去洗手间。就在这时，安迪站起来向大办公区宣布了一件事。他说，也许你们注意到德怀特一直在很努力地为我们做些好事。这不是他的一贯作风。
And he's not having an easy time with it. And like the bullpen's like, who cares? Danley's like so, Meredith's like, what's your game? Andy's like, we need to give him a gift. And Cree's like, who cares? Stanley's like so, Meredith's like, what's your game? And he's like, we need to give him a gift. And Creed's like, what, like a present? Andy continues. He says, Dwight wakes up every day at 4 a.m. and kills the pig. That's his workout. He's not like us, but today he tried.
而且他做起来并不容易。大办公区的人反应是，谁在乎啊？斯坦利觉得无所谓，梅雷迪思觉得，你到底有什么阴谋？安迪说，我们需要送他一份礼物。克里德说，谁在乎啊？斯坦利觉得无所谓，梅雷迪思觉得，你到底有什么阴谋？安迪说，我们需要送他一份礼物。克里德说，什么，像个礼物？安迪继续说道。他说，德怀特每天早上4点起床去杀猪。那是他的锻炼方式。他跟我们不一样，但他今天努力了。
And you know, it wasn't too long ago. I had a temper. I was a real bastard. And do you know what got me out of it? Oscar comes in with some snark and says, mandatory anger management. We're calling back all this stuff. Yeah. And Andy goes, no. And he like wants to shout at Oscar so badly. And Ed is really funny in the scene. He goes, no, the kindness and gentle words of my anger management sponsor.
你知道的，不久前。我脾气很爆。我以前是个彻头彻尾的混蛋。你们知道是什么让我改掉这个毛病的吗？奥斯卡带着讽刺的语气插话说，强制情绪管理。我们把前面这些梗都串起来了。对。然后安迪说，没有。他超级想冲奥斯卡吼。艾德在这场戏里真的超级搞笑。他说，没有，是我情绪管理赞助商的善良和温和的话语。
And his whole thing is, guys, my point is, maybe we can be that for Dwight, we can be that person. Wow. And Phyllis, coming in hard with the sass, says, look, we all do nice things. I bring in muffins at least once a week. And Stanley says, those are leftover book group muffins. Oh my gosh!
他的核心意思是，各位，我的重点是，也许我们也可以对德怀特这样，我们也可以成为那样的人。哇。而菲利斯毫不客气地回怼道，听着，我们都会做善事。我至少每周带一次玛芬蛋糕来。斯坦利说，那是读书会剩下的玛芬蛋糕。哦，天哪！
There's so much sass. Anyway, and he's like, hey, we're getting off topic. He's coming back. Will you guys please give me some money. So when Dwight gets the gift card and it pans to the bull pin, do you see how like everyone is like, whatever? Yeah, that's why.
火药味太浓了。总之，安迪说，嘿，我们偏离主题了。他要回来了。大家能给我点钱吗？所以当德怀特拿到礼品卡，镜头切到大办公区时，你们看到大家都是一副“随便啦”的表情吗？对，这就是原因。
Wow. The shooting draft. The shooting draft. like everyone is like whatever. Yeah, that's why. Wow! The shooting draft. The shooting draft. Well, Michael is going to ask Pam to come in his office. It's about work. It really is. It is. About work.
哇。拍摄剧本。拍摄剧本。大家都是一副“随便啦”的表情。对，这就是原因。哇！拍摄剧本。拍摄剧本。好吧，迈克尔要叫潘去他的办公室。是关于工作的。真的是。是的。关于工作的。
It is. Mm-hmm. He is going to offer her a race. She's going to take it. Yeah. But it's still not changing her mood towards him. No, and he wants her to know that the race has strings attached from his heart to her mean attitude. Pam's like, are you bribing me? And then he's like, what do you want? What do you want? Do you want
是的。嗯哼。他要给她加薪。她接受了。对。但这仍然没有改变她对他的态度。没有，他想让潘知道，这次加薪是有附加条件的，从他的心连到她冷漠的态度。潘说，你是在贿赂我吗？然后他说，你想要什么？你想要什么？你想要
a million dollars? Do you want to hit me? She says, I want to hit you. Lady, this plotline was so controversial. When this ended up airing, oh my gosh, it lit up the message boards. I bet. Not only does she want to hit him, but she says, in the parking lot, in front of everyone, I'm going to hit you as hard as I can. Everyone gets very invested very quickly. There's a lot of chatter around the office. And Toby is like, Pam, can I talk to you for a second? We all think he's human resources
一百万美元吗？你想打我吗？她说，我想打你。天哪，这个剧情太具争议性了。当时这一集播出时，哦天哪，留言板直接炸了。我敢打赌。她不仅想打他，还说，在停车场，在所有人面前，我要狠狠地揍你。大家很快就都入戏了。办公室里有很多议论。托比就说，潘，我能跟你聊一会儿吗？我们都以为他是人事部的人
and he's going to stop this. Yes. But Toby just wants to confirm that she'll be hitting him off property. And then he wants to show her how to throw a punch. Oh my gosh. Charlie Grandy said that Paul is the one who pitched this bit. He pitched it in the room during the rewrite and Charlie said he was pretty new on the office at this time. And when Paul was first pitching it, he thought, well, I don't know how are we going to, how is this going to like play realistically and funny? But Paul was like, I know how to do it. I know how are we gonna, how is this gonna like play realistically and funny? But Paul was like, I know how to do it.
他是来阻止这件事的。对。但托比只是想确认她是不是在私人物业范围外打他。然后他想教她怎么出拳。哦，天哪。查理·格兰迪说，这个桥段是保罗想出来的。他在重写剧本时在房间里提出了这个点子，查理说当时他刚进《办公室》不久。保罗刚提出这个点子时，他心想，好吧，我不知道我们该怎么拍，这拍出来能真实又搞笑吗？但保罗却说，我知道怎么做。我不知道我们该怎么拍，这拍出来能真实又搞笑吗？但保罗却说，我知道怎么做。
I know how to do it. And he said that Paul just did it perfectly. Totally. I also think this whole joke of Toby's showing Pam, how to throw a punch, is a great example of a joke that lives in history in the character. This is part of Toby's history. Yeah. And we have gotten to know Toby so well and we have seen years of Michael giving Toby,
我知道怎么做。他说保罗做得完美极了。完全赞同。我也觉得托比教潘怎么出拳这个笑话，是角色背景故事中一个很好的例子。这是托比背景故事的一部分。对。我们已经非常了解托比了，我们看了多年迈克尔对托比
you know, such a hard time. That of course, of course Toby's going to be like, so the power comes from your back foot. Yeah. And you want to turn because Because it's so clear, the joke is in the subtext that Toby has fantasized about growing a punch at Michael for years. We had a fan catch from Efrat T and Israel, who just wanted to point out that when Michael hit Meredith with this car, he tells Ryan that it was on company grounds because it was the parking lot.
百般刁难。所以理所当然地，托比一定会说，力量是从你的后脚发出来的。对。然后你要转身，因为这个笑话的潜台词太明显了，那就是托比多年来一直幻想对迈克尔挥拳。我们收到了来自以色列的埃弗拉·T的粉丝来信，他只想指出，当迈克尔开车撞到梅雷迪思时，他告诉瑞安这发生在公司地盘上，因为那是停车场。
Oh, good catch. But also in the duel, Andy and Dwight are fighting in the parking lot and Jim tells them not to fight at work. So just kind of pointing out suddenly the parking lot is not company property, at least as far as Toby is concerned. That is a really good catch,
哦，真是个绝佳的发现。但同样在决斗中，安迪和德怀特在停车场打架，吉姆告诉他们不要在工作场所打架。所以这就指出，突然之间停车场又不算公司财产了，至少在托比看来是这样。这真是一个很好的发现，
because technically she'd have to try to throw a punch out in the street. Or at least on the sidewalk. Yeah. Well, speaking of the parking lot, everyone's gathered outside. Kevin's money is on Pam. Oscar notes it's a one-sided fight. It's not really, you know, Pam winning
因为严格来说，她得去马路上出拳。或者至少在人行道上。对。好吧，说到停车场，大家都在外面集合了。凯文押潘赢。奥斯卡指出这是一场单方面的战斗。这其实算不上，你知道的，潘赢
is the only outcome here. Well right now there's no Michael. There's just Pam. We can't find Michael. Meredith checks the mincerum, says the toilet seat is still warm. Hmm. Thanks for putting your hand on the toilet seat, Meredith. I guess so. Kelly has made popcorn. Yes, she has. She's bringing snacks and we find Michael in the stairwell. Yeah. He's clearly trying to psych himself up for this moment. And he walks out to the parking lot.
是这里唯一的结局。好吧，现在没有迈克尔。只有潘。我们找不到迈克尔。梅雷迪思查看了微波炉室，说马桶座圈还是温的。哼。谢谢你把手放在马桶座圈上，梅雷迪思。我猜是的。凯莉做好了爆米花。是的，她做了。她带了零食，然后我们发现迈克尔在楼梯间。对。他显然在为这一刻给自己打气。然后他走到了停车场。
And Pam is going to wind up. She's going to wind up for the punch. He flinches and can I just say that Angela Martin for once is on Pam's side? Oh my gosh, your line is so funny. Pam says, Michael, you have to put your hands down. Angela says, put your hands in your pockets. So this is just another person
潘要蓄力了。她要摆好架势准备出拳。他退缩了，我能说安吉拉·马丁破天荒地站在潘这一边吗？哦天哪，你的台词太搞笑了。潘说，迈克尔，你得把手放下。安吉拉说，把手插进裤兜里。所以这也是另一个
who is excited for Michael to get hit. Well, as Pam is getting ready to hit Michael, he actually stops. He apologizes to her for everything. Pam takes it in and she's like, okay, okay. She says, fine, don't date anyone else in my family ever again. And she's going to walk away. She is. But Michael cannot shut his mouth.
迫不及待想看到迈克尔挨揍的人。好吧，就在潘准备打迈克尔时，他竟然停下来了。他为所有事向她道歉。潘听进去了，她觉得，好吧，好吧。她说，行了，以后别再跟我家任何人约会了。然后她就要走开。她会的。但迈克尔就是管不住他的嘴。
Yeah. He says, for the record, your mom came on to me. Ah! Pam? Pivots on her heel and slaps him so hard across the face. And she's got that superhuman pregnancy strength per Kelly. We got a lot of mail. I might say
对。他说，有一说一，是你妈主动勾引我的。啊！潘？脚后跟一转，狠狠地一巴掌扇在他脸上。据凯莉说，她有着超人般的孕妇神力。我们收到了很多邮件。我可以说是一场
fan mail flurry. Oh. Enoch and from Pennsylvania wants to know did Jenna really slap Steve? And Angela Katie M from Fresno, California said quote, the moment Pam slaps Michael, I absolutely believe Jenna could have played Sydney Bristo on Alia. Oh, Katie. Okay, fine, Katie, I agree. This is a real Pam kickin' some butt moment. Jenna, you nailed it. I am also curious because my character, as you know, slaps two people on this show, and
粉丝来信风暴。哦。来自宾夕法尼亚州的埃诺克想知道，珍娜真的打史蒂夫了吗？来自加利福尼亚州弗雷斯诺的安吉拉·凯蒂·M说，引述如下，“潘扇迈克尔的那一刻，我绝对相信珍娜能在《双面女间谍》里演悉尼·布里斯托。”哦，凯蒂。好吧，好吧，凯蒂，我同意。这是一个真正的潘大显身手的时刻。珍娜，你演绝了。我也很好奇，因为如你所知，我的角色在这部剧里扇了两个人耳光，而且
I really did hit my co-stars. Did you really hit Steve? I did not. Steve said I should hit him. It did not seem safe to me because I am whipping around. If it was just a slap from a standing position, but this was like, I could not bring myself to do it. I think that's really smart because I hit
我确实打了我的联合主演。你真的打史蒂夫了吗？我没有。史蒂夫说我应该打他。这对我来说看起来很不安全，因为我要转身挥臂。如果只是站在原地扇一巴掌还好，但这就像是，我实在下不去手。我觉得这真的很聪明，因为我
Mike sure on the run, your whole body goes into it. And he discussed that slap on our podcast. Yes. Well, our stunt coordinator, Eric Sulkey. Love Eric. Yes, he gave me very detailed instructions on how to pretend slap Steve. And he also worked with Matt Sone
迈克·舒尔在奔跑中拍摄，你的全身都投入进去了。他在我们的播客里讨论过那一巴掌。是的。我们的特技指导埃里克·苏尔基。爱死埃里克了。是的，他给了我非常详细的指导，教我如何假装扇史蒂夫。他还和马特·索恩合作
on positioning the camera behind me so that you couldn't even tell that I'm not hitting him. And then Randy told me that we added that slap sound in post-production. So I did not slap Steve. Well, I'm glad you didn't because also you couldn't see him. Your back was to him. Yes. That's what I was worried about. I mean I was worried that I might make contact but I was very specific like we
把摄像机放在我身后，这样你甚至看不出我没有打他。然后兰迪告诉我，我们在后期制作中添加了那一巴掌的声音。所以我没有扇史蒂夫。好吧，我很高兴你没打，因为你当时也看不到他。你的背对着他。对。这就是我所担心的。我是说我担心可能会真的接触到，但我非常具体，比如我们
lined up our bodies. My pivot was highly choreographed. I just pivoted on that one spot. Yeah. You guys sold it. I thought it totally worked. Well, at the end, Michael is limping away. And... Limpink. I know. And Dwight's like, why are you limping? He's like, I don't know. Well, we had a fan question from M.E.L. in Baltimore, Maryland. Was Michael's limping and Dwight's reactions scripted or improvised. It was scripted. Yeah, when I reread this shooting draft, almost every single thing you see was completely scripted. All the little details.
对准了彼此的身体。我的转身是高度编排的。我只是在那个特定的点上转身。对。你们演得太棒了。我觉得效果完全达到了。好吧，最后，迈克尔一瘸一拐地走开。而且……一瘸一拐的。我知道。德怀特就问，你为什么一瘸一拐的？他说，我不知道。好吧，我们有一个来自马里兰州巴尔的摩的M.E.L.的粉丝提问。迈克尔的一瘸一拐和德怀特的反应是剧本写好的还是即兴发挥的？是剧本写好的。对，当我重新阅读这版拍摄剧本时，几乎你看到的每一个细节都是完全写在剧本里的。所有的细枝末节。
Well, fans had very mixed reactions to this slap. Yeah. A lot of people felt like it was one step too far. They did not like Pam for doing this. I think Steve is so good at playing the vulnerable side of Michael. People were upset. How did we feel about it and rewatching it?
好吧，粉丝们对这一巴掌的反应褒贬不一。对。很多人觉得这有点过分了。他们不喜欢潘这样做。我觉得史蒂夫把迈克尔脆弱的一面演得太好了。粉丝们很不高兴。我们在重看时是怎么看待这件事的？
I mean, I thought, you know, Pam was walking away. She wasn't gonna do it. Mm-hmm. And Michael just couldn't leave it alone. I think that collectively, I remember the writers and producers felt that we couldn't end this story of Michael dating Pam's mom doing this like highly insensitive thing to Pam. Not only did he date her mom, he then broke up with her mom on her birthday
我的意思是，我觉得，你知道的，潘当时正要走开。她不打算打的。嗯哼。而迈克尔就是管不住自己。我想总的来说，我记得编剧和制作人们觉得，我们不能让迈克尔跟潘的妈妈约会、对潘做出这种极度麻木不仁的事情的剧情就这么结束。他不只跟她妈约好了，还在她生日那天
in a public place and he needed a comeuppance. He needed to settle this. He did. Him and Pam needed to settle this. And now it's settled. It's not gonna fester. Yes, he did. Him and Pam needed to settle this. And now it's settled. It's not gonna fester. So that was, I think, the reasoning behind it was that we needed to.
在一个公共场所跟她妈分手了，他需要受到惩罚。他需要了结这件事。他确实需要。他和潘需要了结此事。现在了结了。不会再发酵了。是的，他确实需要。他和潘需要了结此事。现在了结了。不会再发酵了。所以我想这背后的原因就是我们需要这样做。
This was now, it's been resolved. You know, there were a few relationships on the show that reminded me of siblings. Like Angela Oscar and Kevin. They were almost like siblings, you know? Stanley and Phyllis. Stanley and Phyllis. And I felt like Pam and Michael were like brother and sister. I think that's a really good analogy.
这下总算解决了。你知道，剧中有一些人物关系让我想起兄弟姐妹。比如安吉拉、奥斯卡和凯文。他们简直就像兄弟姐妹一样，你知道吗？斯坦利和菲利斯。斯坦利和菲利斯。我觉得潘和迈克尔就像兄妹一样。我觉得这是一个非常贴切的比喻。
But yeah, I remember people were really chatting about this. Dwight is gonna bring Michael inside and he says he's got some chicken. He can put on that, call back to all that chicken on the microwave. Fan question from Victoria H and Columbus, Ohio, was Dwight holding real raw chicken on Michael's face or did Phil Shea make that? Well, both. It is real chicken. That Phil Shea shrink wrapped. So it was real, but it was like covered in something so that...
但是，是的，我记得大家真的在热烈讨论这件事。德怀特把迈克尔带进屋里，说他有一些鸡肉。他可以把它敷在脸上，呼应了微波炉里所有鸡肉的梗。来自俄亥俄州哥伦布市的维多利亚·H的粉丝提问，德怀特贴在迈克尔脸上的真的是生鸡肉，还是菲尔·谢伊制作的道具？好吧，两者皆是。那是真的鸡肉。被菲尔·谢伊用保鲜膜包起来了。所以它是真的，但外面裹了点东西，好让……
Wow. It's so gross. I thought for sure you're gonna say, no, it's a fakie rubber chicken thing. No, it was real chicken. Walsers. Yeah. Well, Dwight thinks he finally did his favor
哇。太恶心了。我还以为你一定会说，不，那是假的橡胶鸡玩具。不，那是真鸡肉。沃尔瑟斯。好吧，德怀特觉得他终于做了一件好事
and he says, fire Jim. Michael's like, no, Dwight is angry and takes his dinner away. Yeah, he's gonna eat that after it was on Michael's face. Apparently. You know, I feel like this episode wraps up best with the talking head that Michael had. Yes, I feel like I need to read it.
然后他说，炒了吉姆。迈克尔说，不，德怀特很生气，把他的晚餐拿走了。对，他要在那块贴过迈克尔脸的鸡肉放过之后吃掉它。显然是的。你知道，我觉得这一集最好以迈克尔的独白作结。是的，我觉得我需要读一下。
Okay, please do. As I watched Pam's big, strong hand coming towards my face, I saw my entire life flash before my eyes. And guess what? I have four kids and I have a hover car and a hover house. And my wife is a runner and it shows. And Pam and Jim are my best friends and our kids play together. And I am happy and I am rich and I never die. It doesn't sound like much but it's enough for me. There you have it. There you have it. Michael in the inn just sees them as his family. Always, always. Next week you guys buckle in because it is murder. Ugh, this is one of my biggest memes.
好的，请读吧。当我看着潘那只巨大有力、朝我的脸挥过来的手时，我看到我的一生在眼前闪过。你猜怎么着？我有四个孩子，我有一辆悬浮车和一个悬浮房。我妻子是个跑步健将，而且成效显著。潘和吉姆是我最好的朋友，我们的孩子一起玩耍。我很幸福，我很富有，我永远不会死。听起来好像没什么，但对我来说足够了。就是这样。就是这样。迈克尔内心深处只是把他们当成他的家人。永远，永远。下周大家系好安全带，因为这一集是谋杀案。啊，这是我最喜欢的表情包之一。
Me too! People tagged me all the time as Voodoo Mama Juju. That was double date everyone. Listen, check your glutes and maybe pick up some three penis wine if your muscles are hinking after your glute check. We should probably go get some right now, and just skip the three penis wine if your muscles are hinking. After your glute check, we should probably go get some right now, Ange. Skip the three penis wine. We love you.
我也是！大家经常把我标记为巫毒妈妈朱朱。那是双人约会，各位。听着，检查一下你们的臀肌，如果你在臀肌检查后肌肉酸痛，也许可以去买点三鞭酒。我们现在可能应该去买一些，如果你肌肉酸痛的话，就跳过三鞭酒。安吉，在做完臀肌检查后，我们现在应该去买一些。跳过三鞭酒。我们爱你们。
See you next week. Have a great one. Thank you for listening to Office Ladies. Office Ladies is produced by Ear Wolf, Jennifer Fisher, and Angela Kinsey. Our show is executive produced by Cody Fisher. Our producer is Cassie Jerkins. Our sound engineer is Sam Keeper and our associate producer is Ainsley Bubaco.
下周见。祝大家过得愉快。感谢收听“办公室淑女”。“办公室淑女”由Ear Wolf、珍妮弗·费舍尔和安吉拉·金西联合制作。我们的执行制片人是科迪·费舍尔。我们的制作人是卡西·杰金斯。我们的音响工程师是萨姆·基珀，副制作人是艾恩斯利·布巴科。
Our theme song is rubber tree by Creed Ratten. For add-free versions of Office Ladies, go to Stitcher Premium.com. For a free one month trial at Stichopremium Use Code Office. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
我们的主题曲是克里德·拉滕的《橡胶树》。想要无广告版的“办公室淑女”，请访问Stitcher Premium.com。使用优惠码Office即可免费试用一个月Stitcher Premium。本集还没有评论。点击字幕中的任意句子即可留下评论。